(chewing)
- Chewy bread doesn't taste
good with the chocolate
that they put in there.
- I'll fuck with it.
- Joey you fuck with anything.
- Joey's like, is that fucking weird?
I'll fuck with that.
- Is this seasoned vomit?
I mean, I'ma try it.
(groovy music)
- What's up you crazy konbini cunts?
Welcome to another episode.
(laughing)
That wasn't my idea.
That was Garnt's.
- I know you've been hanging
out with Aki too much.
'Cause that was the most
American sounding cunt
I've ever heard.
- Really?
- Yeah that was like the hard C, dude.
That is like actually the most
offensive thing you can say
to an Australian.
- POV you're a YouTube channel
waving goodbye to monetization.
So what are we doing today Joey?
What's the theme of today's episode?
- Well the theme of today's episode
is Japanese convenience stores.
I didn't just say konbini in the intro
for shits and giggles.
Like we're going to be talking konbinis
as it's called in Japan.
Because Japan I feel is
the only country where
the word convenience in
the word convenience store
actually, you know, means what it means.
- I think there's a lot
of places in Asia where
convenience stores are very convenient
but definitely as someone
who's traveled around,
Japan's up there.
- It's just built different.
(laughing)
- Japan's up there, some of
the best convenience stores
in the world.
- Absolutely.
- And you've seen all those videos,
there's YouTube is with
the, you know, Kevin MacLeod
or whatever the fuck he's called.
Copyright free music playing
in the background being like,
these are my favorite 10 konbini snacks.
That's not what we're doing today.
We're going to crack open--
- The konbini halls?
- Yeah, the konbini.
We're just going to crack
open a bunch of beers,
just start eating shit
and just saying words.
That's how we do it.
- Part of this is we want
to represent our team
because I am team 7-11.
He is team Lawson.
and he is team Family Mart.
- I'm team Family Mart.
- I just think Lawson's
is built different.
They've just figured it out.
Like Family Mart?
Okay honestly like, 7-11
I respect the choice.
Family Mart?
You're actually just
like, you have zero taste.
- I agree.
Family Mart is the clown pick right here.
7-11, we are a global conglomerate.
We have not just taken over Japan.
We are fricking everywhere in Asia.
And I'm gonna prove--
- And that's why they've been tainted
by all the other countries.
- And I'm going to prove why
today 7-11 is the biggest
convenience store.
- Mind you,
there's more than these three
convenience stores in Japan.
There's like the smaller ones
like Mini Stop, Daily Yamazaki.
I fuck with Daily Yamazaki.
- Do you?
Everyone I know.
I think I asked Chris, I'm like,
do you like Daily Yamazaki?
And Chris was like,
no that's fucking awful.
- Chris is the whitest
man alive, what does he know?
- He's like me.
That's why I can trust his opinion.
- He's like finally, another white man.
- Chris, I need another
white British man opinion.
Is this good?
No it's shit.
All right.
- No, whenever I go to like Daily Yamazaki
or one of the smaller chains
it's like going to
fucking Audi's or Iceland
in the UK.
- You never see
these convenience stores.
Now, if you don't know anything
about convenience stores
they are pretty much
found every 100 meters.
- Yeah.
Literally every block of land
there's at least one konbini, I find.
- Literally, when you like
look into houses to rent,
one of the selling points is literally
the meters away from the
nearest convenience store.
When you're looking at listing for houses.
That's how much they
care about convenience.
- If you live in Tokyo,
there'll most 100% be
like three within your vicinity.
- Absolutely, yeah.
- And even when you go rural areas
you're driving around,
there'll be nothing.
And then out of the distance--
- Suddenly there's a konbini.
- You'll just see this perfect
immaculate 7-11 just there.
And it's great because
it's not like a gas station
where you're like, fuck.
God, I gotta go,
there's hot dogs that are
probably gonna give me salmonella.
I'm probably not gonna like this.
It's legit good food.
So we picked a bunch of items today
that we all kind of liked.
Or that we could find.
Cause sometimes the item's not available.
- We pick the items that we normally buy
when we go to our
convenience store of choice.
And then we got our intern
to buy a lot of other random
shit from convenience
stores, just to show to you
what--
- Go out of our comfort zone
a little bit.
- Yeah, going out of our comfort zone
just to show you what is available
at Japanese konbinis.
- Yeah we definitely haven't tried
all the things we're
going to talk about today.
So it's kind of a learning experience.
Also, if you're an audio only listener
this is just going to be eating ASMR.
You should probably
tune into YouTube.
- Highly recommend.
This is going to be the
closest to the figure episode
that we've released in a while
where if you're an audio
only listener, I apologize.
But yeah.
Shall we just kind of jump
right into it, gentlemen?
- Sure.
- Now I think I know
what I want to start off
because this is the debate
that I think started this episode idea,
which is fried chicken.
- Right.
- Now, I don't care about how good
the rest of the konbini food is.
How I judge konbinis is the fried chicken.
- Right, right.
- Because when I moved to Japan, you know,
we think that a lot of
Americans, you know,
they would like to stan
their fried chicken,
but a lot of the best fried chicken I've
had has come from Asia.
And konbini fried chicken
is way too fucking good.
It should be illegal to make
fried chicken taste this good.
- It's like restaurant
quality fried chicken.
- Yeah, yeah.
- So when you go to the konbini
there'll be hot food sections, right,
Where you can get various
amounts of hot food,
but the fried chicken is
like the selling point.
They'll often have a whole section.
- It's like probably the
first thing you'll see.
- And it normally comes in as,
as the gentleman will show you.
It comes in this little
pouch like this, right?
- Well, it doesn't come in the pouch,
it's on display on like a heating rack.
But they put it in a pouch.
- And then they put it in a pouch.
And what you can do is you
just rip off half the pouch,
- Unless you're Lawson and you
have to open it from the top
like a madman.
- I don't mind that.
I don't mind squeezing it out.
This is the Lawson fried, look
at that, look at that man.
Is that not?
- Family.
- Look.
Okay.
Convenience store points down,
Because look how convenient it is.
- Yeah, exactly.
Look at the convenience of this.
- Look at that, look at that.
- Where's the fucking seasoning on that?
There's nothing on there.
- Okay.
I'd like to just give a huge disclaimer.
I'm personally not a huge fan of this.
(laughing)
I think I'm like one in a million where
I almost never buy the fried
chicken at convenience stores.
- Right.
Why?
- Cause I don't really like
fried chicken to begin with.
- Now this is the standard,
just pepper and salt fried chicken.
But at Lawson's you can get like
a ton of different variations.
They have one that is like, it's like a,
it's like a Chinese sweet and sour one.
And it's like black.
And I don't know why it
doesn't look good at all,
but it's fucking amazing.
- I don't know.
That just, I've never tried it,
but it just looks--
- Chinese sweet and sour,
I know, I know.
- 'Cause it's a literal black chicken,
and it looks like someone,
it's like someone took a chicken
and just dunked it in squid oil.
That's what it looks like.
- What I think we should do
is we should cut up three pieces.
We should trade pieces.
- Okay.
We should trade piece.
Okay.
- My hands are greasy.
Can we get like napkins galore by the way?
- Okay. I'm going to, I'm
going to take the knife
and then I'm going to cut up three pieces.
- Do mine as well.
Now here's the thing,
these chicken right now.
They're not going to
look at peak condition
because we had to microwave these.
Normally they're crispy.
They're nice and crispy.
- They come in piping hot.
- Fresh out the oven.
- Yeah I just cut two pieces.
So you guys can take and
I'll just take this half.
- Fantastic.
- Fan fucking tastic.
- There we go, there's
two pieces for you boys.
- And also if you're not really
into like a whole breast,
that's fine, 'cause a lot
of them also have like,
the like, nuggets, like substitute.
Thank you.
- All right here you go.
I'ma hand these over to you.
- Okay, let's give it a shot.
- Alright, let's--
- This is like the last supper,
but Family Mart edition.
- We're not sharing the bread.
We're sharing the chicken.
- Joey if you will do me the honor.
Okay.
- [Joey] Grab one of these.
- Grab one of these.
- I'll try it.
Should we try the Family
Mart chicken first?
- Let's go bottom up.
- Let's start with Family Mart.
- You know what, the
crispiness looks good.
The color looks good.
I'm down for it.
That was very wet.
Look at the grease
that's left on my plate.
- There is a lot of grease in there.
- Out of all of these,
out of all of these, like,
The Family Mart one has
almost left a puddle.
(laughing)
- It's just actually like,
kinda, I'm gonna eat it.
- Yeah, like, look.
You can tell this is Family Mart chicken
because it's like compared
to the Seven chicken,
this one ain't,
This one can't be white.
'Cause it's gonna stain the white one.
- It's just going to go straight through.
- It's gonna go straight through.
- So I'm gonna...
- It is very fatty and very greasy.
I feel like there's no breast.
It's not good.
- It is, ugh.
- Obviously, if you know,
I'm in the middle of nowhere,
I'm in Hokkaido.
I want a beer and a fried chicken.
It's going to do the job.
But when there's Lawson's
and you know, 7-11.
- Again, I will happily take this L
because I don't even eat
fried chicken to begin with.
- Yeah, okay.
My problem with Family
Mart fried chicken is that
it tastes like death.
(laughing)
You know, sometimes when
you're eating and you realized,
wait a minute, I'm eating
a dead animal right now.
That is what Family Mart
chicken tastes like.
- It feels like they inject
it with stuff as well.
- I feel like that too, yeah.
- Let's try the 7-11 one now, shall we?
- Okay, okay.
- Shit, which one's the 7-11 one?
- It'll be this one, this color.
- The slightly orange one.
- Yeah.
- It's pretty good.
- The reason.
The reason I stan 7-11 and the
reason it's my favorite one
is because of their fried chicken.
- This one's also quite fatty.
- It's fatty enough where it's less
than the Family Mart chicken.
It's the perfect amount.
You know when you...
You know when you want a
beer and you just want to
eat something unhealthy?
This is the perfect amount
of oil and unhealthiness
that doesn't make you feel
like you're eating death.
It still makes you feel
like you're eating,
like something that you
shouldn't be enjoying every day.
It's a bit of a...
- I have to say, I think
in terms of the seasoning?
- They seasoned the fuck out of that.
- It's way better than the Family Mart.
- I think out of all of them, this, like,
with Lawson's they have way more choice
in the chicken seasoning.
Like there's like the spicy seasoning.
- Yeah I do this this is
gonna be the weakest one
out of the choices that Lawson's have.
I'm not trying to like, you know,
put myself in a corner, but
like, yeah, I'm just saying.
- Like out of everything,
7-11 does just, just does the
basic fried chicken the best.
Has the best seasoning.
- I'll agree.
Doesn't need anything
fancy, no spicy chicken.
It's just pure, here's what
fried chicken should taste like,
salt and pepper, seasoned perfectly,
the right amount of oil.
It is the best fried chicken.
- Okay let's try this Lawson one,
because I've realized immediately that
in terms of the thickness of chicken,
this is probably the thickest.
- The thick one.
You're getting good chicken.
- That's like a proper amount of chicken.
- This is a proper amount of,
here's the chicken, and here's the...
- That could be a tendie
dude, that's so good.
- Yeah exactly.
- It honestly tastes
like a tendie as well.
- Just the right amount of juicy.
- Actually you know what?
I think that might be my favorite.
- Right?
- It tastes more like a chicken
tender than like a breast.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It tastes like, the closest
to KFC for some reason.
You know what I mean?
- I agree, I agree.
- I think it needs more seasoning.
- Yeah. This is what I mean,
like take that chicken, right?
And then actually put like a
fuckton of seasoning on it.
Make it spicy.
That's the best.
- Because that's the reason
I stan the 7-11 chicken.
It is,
It is, like I'd say there's less fat
than the 7-11 chicken.
But the 7-11 chicken just
has the best seasoning.
And why do we eat fried chicken?
It's because of the seasoning.
Like, you know.
- 11 secret herbs and spices.
- Like imagine buying KFC chicken
and then all the skin's off.
No one would want to eat
that shit, let's be honest.
You eat it because of the skin,
because of the seasoning
on the fried chicken.
So I will go, you know,
I will fight you on this.
- So let's rate one two three.
I personally would say
Lawson, 7-11, Family Mart.
- I'd say the same for me personally.
I'm biased obviously, it's mine.
- I'd say--
- I mean you two are a little more biased.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'd say 7-11, Lawson's, Family
Mart right at the bottom.
- We can all agree that Family Mart's
at the bottom in this case.
- As the third opinion in the room, Joey,
I suppose you've put it
over the edge for Lawson's.
- I would have to give a point to Lawson.
- [Connor] I will say though.
- The seasoning for 7-11 is good.
But I think it's like too
much seasoning for me.
- Yeah. Yeah.
They also do nuggets.
Now these are the basic kind
which you'd never catch me finding.
I just, I don't really care for it.
I want spice.
There's like, there's a hot version.
And I think there's a cheese version.
I don't fuck with the cheese versions.
'Cause it's like injected cheese.
I don't trust that,
cheese should be on top.
It should never be injected.
- [Joey] Right.
- There's some things
that should be injected.
Cheese isn't one of them.
- Cheese ain't one of them.
- Vaccines, check.
- Medicine?
Medicine, check.
- And these have been microwaved,
'cause we've heated them up.
But yeah, they don't look
too great not gonna lie,
you guys want to try a nugget?
The color on this chicken
is kind of tragic looking,
I wanna say.
I did eat one before
recording 'cause I was
getting really hungry.
- This looks actually,
this is the most depressing chicken nugget
I've ever seen.
- You know what this looks
like, this looks like,
this is like frozen.
- Yeah look how yellow this is.
- It was once frozen
and I just defrosted it.
- It's like, it lacks any kind of color
that makes it look,
that would make it look appealing.
- Oh, no.
Oh no.
- Not any good.
They had a slam dunk.
- Lawson's, 7-11, Family Mart,
and then whatever the fuck I just ate.
- Okay, that was worse than
the Family Mart chicken.
I said the Family Mart
chicken tastes like death.
Oh my God.
That was--
- That tastes right out the freezer.
Oh my God.
- You know what this tastes like?
This tastes like--
- Can you show it, put it like, stab it,
and share it to the camera?
- Look at that.
- This for real tastes like--
- The skin is like dying to get off it.
- This is like one of
those karaages you order
at a really, really cheap izakaya.
- It's like 50 yen fried chicken.
- 50 yen for one, yeah.
That ain't it, chief.
- Man. The fried, but I mean, honestly,
you can't really go wrong
unless you go Family Mart.
- Yeah, I would say the
reason that, I mean we, okay,
so where we live right now,
we live right next to a Family Mart
and we live right next to a Lawson's.
Unfortunately we don't
live next to a 7-11.
And that's a shame for me.
Cause some of my best food
items, like the fried chicken,
and like some of the other things
I'm going to show off today is from 7-11.
- That's why like every
time you see a 7-11
it's like an event or it's like (gasps).
- Definitely.
- It's like a random encounter.
- I'm like, yo, I can get
a friend chicken right now?
I'll be right back.
- I just had lunch but
finna grab a fried chicken
real quick.
- Be right back boys.
- They also have a bunch
of, it's not just these.
They have tons of other hot food items.
They have like, it's like a
pita bread with like fillings
like folded up and then they microwave it.
Is that what you have?
- Well, and the other one
that I have right here,
well, no, the one I have here
is like a kushi.
Like skewered meats.
- Oh, I have that as well.
- Oh, okay, yeah.
- So these are like the snack ones.
They have like, pseudo-meat.
- Again, I don't think I've
ever ordered these before,
but it looked like that.
- That just looks like a yakiniku.
I have never ordered.
- This is yakitori.
- Also yeah, yakitori.
- Yeah, yakitori.
- I've never ordered this.
- I've never ordered this either.
Should we get some of that off?
- I don't have a yakitori.
- You don't?
Well you can try some of mine on.
- Honestly, these don't look like,
you look at, you look at these on camera
and they don't look any
different from each other at all.
I couldn't tell which one, the Lawson's...
- [Joey] Can I grab one of those?
- Yakitori is, and I can't tell which one
is the Family Mart yakitori.
(laughing)
I've never gotten the yakitori.
Which is like skewered, like
barbecued skewered meats.
- Just feels like I'm playing with fire.
You know what I mean?
- Because these, both of these,
the color of them.
- They look awful.
- The coloring, just,
there is no coloring at all.
- Don't go to like any
kind of convenience store
to get yakitori, there's plenty of amazing
yakitori restaurants all over Tokyo.
It's so cheap as well.
Normally you can buy per skewer.
- Yeah.
It's like, you know, some
of the cheaper places
are like 30 yen a skewer.
- I'll try the Family Mart one first.
- Okay. Let's try the Family Mart.
- That's awful.
That's so bad.
- That is bad.
That is bad.
Okay.
- I think this has to be fresh
because we microwave these.
- Yeah.
This, what this tastes like is,
they didn't know how to flavor this.
So they just put as much
salt on this as possible.
- Yeah this is salted like fucking crazy.
- This is salt and oil.
What I'm tasting right now
is just very salty oil.
- I just stabbed into the Lawson
and it like squirted oil.
Straight up squirted oil.
- Alright, let me try the...
- Let's try the Lawson one.
- Let me try the Lawson's one.
- They're just both as bad as each other.
- Yeah, they're not that good.
- Yeah that's pretty fucking bad.
- Bottom line, don't go
to a convenience store
to get yakitori.
Lots of amazing izakayas and
restaurants to go to for that.
- You alright Garnt?
- Yeah.
I'm trying to, I'm trying to
chew this and swallow this.
- I felt like we need a drink to go along
with this amazing food.
- Ashley, get us a drink!
- [Ashley] Yes sir.
- Have we talked about Ashley
before on this podcast?
- We talked about him
on the live stream.
- On the livestream
that we did, but yes.
We now have a intern.
We hired our new intern Ashley.
What he did was he sent a full CV to us.
(laughing)
- What did you get Ashley?
No!
No Ashley!
What, why?
- Do you actually have a
beer so I can wash this down?
- Oh, no.
Oh no.
- At least he did us a
favor and got the mini ones.
- Do you wanna explain what this is Joey?
- Okay, so this is Ozeki's one cup sake.
Which is essentially the like
trailer trash level of sake
that you can get at convenience stores.
- Imagine Budweiser
trying to make a cheap
version of Budweiser.
And this is what you would get.
- This is the Blue
Lightning of sake, right?
So how much does one of these cost?
These cost like a dollar a pop, right?
- It's like 100 yen, yeah.
- [Ashley] 250.
- Okay, it's 250 yen.
- That's too much for this.
- So this costs about $2.
It's literally a jar of sake.
- And we all know how much I love sake.
- Yeah.
- From the episode with Chris.
- None of us have tried this, right?
- I've never tried
this before.
this either.
So I'm not even a big fan of sake
in the first place.
- I like sake,
but it's--
- Well actually.
- It's like wine, right?
Like I need the right food for it.
And this is not the right food for it.
- If you calculate the
price per milliliter.
This is actually more expensive
than the one Chris brought us, so.
- Could that actually?
- If it's 250 yen, yeah.
- Oh yeah, probably.
- So Chris you fucking cheap mother.
I'm joking, I'm kidding.
- Well it doesn't smell horrible.
- It's sake, it never
smells of anything much.
- It doesn't smell too bad.
- I mean, it smells like sake.
What does bad sake smell like?
- A bad sake will smell sour.
Like you'll know.
- Okay, why, that's like
having milk and being like,
this smells sour.
- Legit, like--
- Do you wanna give me this shit,
do you wanna throw it away?
- Yeah.
Legit, like I've had bad
sake before and it's sour.
It's like sour milk, but
like, sake, it's horrible.
All right.
Well I guess we got to try this huh?
- So should we all do it at the same time?
- Yeah.
- Cheers.
- Cheers, gentlemen.
- To a successful podcast, I hope.
- Yes.
- All right, let's give
it a shot shall we?
Oh God.
- That's actually not bad.
- That's not bad.
- That's not bad at all actually.
- What?
I was not.
I was expecting a burn,
or a bad after taste.
That's not bad.
- You know what?
I can't believe I'm saying this.
I'm kind of fucking with this.
Like it actually tastes all right.
- You want mine?
You want mine?
I don't fuck with that.
- This man just cannot drink sake.
This is actually,
I was expecting it to feel
like I'm drinking petrol.
- Yeah.
That's what I was expecting as well.
Damn, Japan.
This is the cheap alternative
to like getting pissed in Japan?
- I can see why all these, like, you know,
like old people go into,
you know, 7-11 or wherever,
buy one of these and just
chill at the front of the 7-11.
Like I would probably be there as well.
- Honestly this is why we like,
this is why konbinis are great.
'Cause sometimes you buy something
and it's way better than you expect to buy
at a convenience store.
This sake tastes way
too good for something
that just came out of a 250
yen convenience store sake.
- It's okay.
- It's actually not bad.
Wow.
- It doesn't really taste of much.
- That's what I mean, it's easy to drink.
- It's really easy to drink.
- 'Cause a lot of like cheap sake
usually has like a very harsh
flavor.
- Honestly it's less,
I think it's less
offensive than the one that
Chris brought the other day.
- This actually tastes better
than what Chris brought.
- Yeah, yeah yeah.
So Chris fucked us over, thanks Chris.
- I'm still gonna to my beer.
- That's what I'm saying,
it's the milliliter up to price ratio.
But go on, you have two
more hot food items,
what the fuck are they?
- I do, I do, I don't know
what Ashley has bought me.
But let's let's have a look.
Okay so the first one looks like a koroke.
- What the?
A potato?
- Yeah, so what a koroke is
is kind of just like
a potato katsu, right?
That's the way I would describe it.
So sometimes, oh, that is,
that is very oily.
- That's an oily boy!
- That is a very oily boy.
Look at that.
- Do we have more plates?
- Jesus Christ.
- This is literally, oh my God.
- You're going to get the desk all oily.
- Look how, that is literally see-through.
That is, that is a see through.
- That is like the Simpsons episode
with like Dr. Nick.
- This is the Simpsons episode right here.
So what this is, I don't know what kind
of koroke this is.
- You sure you wanna
crack that open on the table?
- Yeah it's all right.
Let's do it.
- Oh, okay.
It's not a koroke.
What is this?
- Oh it's mince katsu.
- Okay, so it's not a koroke, it's katsu.
- It's like minced meat katsu, basically.
- Okay, I've never had this before.
- So essentially, you know what this is?
This is literally a deep fried hamburger.
This is what this is.
This is literally what this is,
it's a deep fried hamburger.
This is, look at that.
This is basically a
hamburger, this is horrible.
- It doesn't smell bad.
You know what it smells like?
It reminds me of like pies in the UK.
- It does.
- Yeah, a little bit.
It's like a mince pie.
- It has a very pie smell.
Oh my God.
I don't know if you can see this on camera
but the oil has seeped.
- That's disgusting.
- The oil has seeped through to the table.
- It doesn't really taste of anything.
Like meat and grease.
That's all I taste.
There's like no seasoning.
- Oh my God.
This tastes like, you know?
Actually you don't know.
How do you eat something
and just have zero
opinion about the taste?
- This tastes alright.
- Yeah it tastes like nothing.
- This literally tastes like cardboard.
Because there's no taste in it at all.
Like you'd expect the burger
to have some kind of seasoning on it.
This tastes like batter.
- Yeah.
- Granted I've had really good mince katsu
and this is definitely
- That's weak sauce.
- weak sauce compared to what I have.
- What else did you get, Garnt?
- Okay, okay.
Do you wanna see this?
- Yeah, sure.
- It's a spring roll.
- You haven't all gotten
a spring roll from that?
- Oh, oh, look at that.
- Look at that.
- [Joey] That just looks sad.
I do not stan this.
Look at that.
Okay.
I'm going to cut this up.
You know what this is?
- You know it's not good when
you're cutting a spring roll
and it turns flat.
It's a soggy spring roll right?
- Oh.
Oh.
- I don't like spring rolls in general.
- What?
- Yeah, I don't like spring rolls.
They're way too oily for me.
- That's not bad.
- Actually that's not bad at all.
- Is it?
How's it taste?
How does it taste?
- It's quite fatty somehow.
Like oily.
- It is very fatty.
You know what?
It tastes like a dim sum.
- Yeah.
A little bit.
It's like the kind of oilyness.
- Like a really bad one.
- Yeah it's like an oiliness of a dim sum.
- Yeah I can see that actually.
- You know when you, 'cause
in the UK we have these like
party platter things that
you get from Iceland.
- That's what it looks like.
- Yeah.
So you thought you were
just gonna get a bite
of just pure like, just pastry.
Was it pastry, is that what it is?
- Yeah, I think it's pastry.
- Pastry, and then just,
maybe like a crumb of meat.
And like that's normally how it is.
That's why I hate spring rolls, but that?
- That one was packed.
- You know, I'd get that.
- I would actually get that, yeah.
- Honestly, I did not expect
it to taste that good.
It tastes like, yeah.
Like you said, like a mini dim sum,
but in a spring roll pastry.
Wow.
That was not the taste I was expecting.
- That's points for 7-11.
- I thought they would somehow
make this one work and
fuck up the spring roll.
- Yeah, right?
- It was the opposite way around.
- You surprise us.
- But there's tons of stuff
that we don't have here,
the hot foods.
Like they change all the time.
Like for example,
Lawson's has like hot dogs
that have like different
toppings, like salsa.
There's like meat.
- I mean, let's not forget it as well,
about like the nikkumans and the pizzamans
and stuff like that.
I think all of the
convenience stores have those.
- Nikkuman, what's it called,
just like a steamed bun?
- Yeah, a steamed meat bun, yeah.
- So you can get like the
Chinese steamed meat buns.
- See them in all the animes.
- Yeah.
- Honestly, like all of the meat buns
in all three of the konbinis are lit.
- And they taste really good.
They taste way too good.
- They taste really good.
- And those are really good.
I'd fuck with the hot dogs,
hot dogs are pretty fucking good.
- What are they called, the goo dogs?
- Goo dogs they're called.
And at one point, okay.
So they also go through at all the chains.
They all go through seasonal items.
One point they had like, mini burritos.
- Mini burritos?
- Yeah, like microwaveable
burritos that were like
the size of that spring roll.
- Like proper,
like proper burritos?
- No.
- If there's one food item that I think
is really hard to get in Japan or one
food cuisine, Mexican food.
- Mexican food, yeah.
- It's so hard to get good
Mexican food in Japan.
You can get any other, any other
food, I feel like I've had,
I've gone to a restaurant
and I've been like, yeah,
this is almost as good.
- The only way you can get
Mexican food is to go to like
international chains that
just happen to be here right?
- Yeah, yeah.
And even then, like, we've been
to some Mexican restaurants.
- On my plate so we can
get rid of this shit.
- We've been to some Mexican restaurants
and I've always felt underwhelmed.
- Oh yeah.
- It's always, it's always
felt like the Mexican--
- But it's sad because that's
the best you're gonna get.
- Yeah exactly, exactly.
We need more good Mexican in Japan.
I'm putting that out there
right now because Mexican,
Mexican food fucking slaps.
- I get really sad 'cause
I watch on like YouTube,
I watch like, there's like,
Food Insider or whatever
the fuck they're called,
like videos, like, the
10 best burritos in LA.
And I'm like, Oh my God, all
of them look fucking amazing.
But yeah, no.
I mean, there's, there's other food items
as well that are hot.
Like you can get actual, like full meals.
You can get instant ramen,
which is like, it's like a
solid, like frozen broth?
I'm not really sure.
It's a block.
- It's like freeze dried.
- It's a freeze dried
block, and it basically,
when you microwave it, that
it melts and makes a broth.
That's actually like better
than most of the shit
you'll get ever in like America.
- Oh hands down, yeah.
- You know, even like some
restaurants I've been to,
they say ramen. And it was
like definitely not ramen.
- Not ramen, yeah.
- It's actually not bad.
There's also, you can get,
I think Garnt has one of them with us.
So there's a bunch of variations.
Lawson's does a ton of like,
I mean there's pastas as well.
I remember as well.
- Yeah the pastas are lit.
- Pastas are, weird
combinations of pastas as well.
Like stuff that like you would never see
ever in Europe.
- Very Japanese twist on Italian food.
What's a weird combination they have?
They'll have like,
fucking like egg and
tomato sauce or something.
- Yeah, something like that.
- They put hot dogs in their pasta,
some pastas as well.
- Yes, they put hot dogs.
- Sausages in their pasta.
- Yes, sausages, tomato
sauce and spaghetti,
and it's like, okay.
Alright.
- Some of the pastas literally
look like a kid's meal.
- It's true, it's true.
They look like the dairy meal lunch pack,
Lunchables or something like that.
You know when you're a kid
and you kind of make your own like,
sandwich out of the Lunchables.
That's like the equivalent
of putting into Japanese,
sorry, Italian cuisine.
- Yeah.
- Lawson's has like a premium
hot food section, which is,
doesn't include any that pasta shit.
It's only Japanese and
normally fried food.
But there is gyudon, and, pudon?
- Gyudon.
- Do you know what gyudon is?
- Butadon?
- Butadon, butadon,
that's what it is, yeah.
Butadon and gyudon.
Which is like, gyudon is just like,
I guess strips of beef and then grilled
and then put with rice and
you normally get like a sauce
or a mayo to dip it in
and put it in the rice.
And then butadon which is
my favorite, is just pork.
Like strips of pork.
- Pork on,
just pork on some rice.
- It's a pork bowl or a beef bowl,
we're about to show you.
- This episode is sponsored by Harry's!
- [Connor] Too often we're choosing
between quality or a fair price.
With Harry's, you don't
have to choose gentlemen.
They give you award-winning blades
at factory direct prices.
- They give us both
quality and fair price?
- I thought that was illegal.
- I thought that was illegal as well.
- Now I will have to ask
boys when you got your first
Harry's razor set and shaved with it.
What surprised you most about
the quality of the products?
- Well, for one, it comes
in a lovely cardboard box.
And look look at the packaging on this.
- This looks clean as fuck, look at that.
- Goddamn.
- What do you go got there in your hand?
- I have here the body wash
which Meilyne literally said
earlier, and I quote, "if you're lonely,
"you can know what a
boyfriend smells like."
(laughing)
- I mean they're literally
giving life to dreams.
For a limited time,
Harry's is offering their starter set
plus a free body wash for just three,
okay, that's actually pretty nice.
- Three bucks?
- That is fucking great.
- At harrys.com/trashtaste.
- You can see us live reacting to this
as we're reading it.
- That is literally the
first time I've read that.
That's actually fucking--
- Is it actually three dollars?
- It's actually three dollars.
- That's actually really good.
- That is really good.
- That is our genuine reaction
as a matter of fact.
And that comes with the shave cream,
a razor with a very
nice handle, by the way.
We also have two razor heads.
So when the first one runs out.
And I don't know what that final thing,
oh it's a storage thing for your razor.
That's cute.
And did you know that
Harry delivers a close
but comfortable shave at a fair price?
Only two dollars a refill, gentlemen.
- That is really fucking good.
- That's actually really good.
- For what you're getting, oh my god.
- [Connor] Harry believes
in quality so much
that they bought their
own factory in Germany
so they could own every step
of the manufacturing process.
- Now that's an epic gamer move.
- I mean, it's German.
So, you know, they're getting shit done!
- But I'm sitting here and I'm wondering,
how do they do it, Garnt?
- [Garnt] Harry's team combined
a simple ergonomic design
with five sharp blades.
They source their steel from Sweden
and manufacture their blades
in their world-class blade factory.
- [Connor] Harry's German factory
is one of the few selected
manufacturers in the world that
have mastered the technology
to create a Gothic arch.
The gold standard for
razor blade grinders.
- And they have a 100% quality guarantee.
They stand behind the quality
of their blade so much
that they have a 100% money
back guarantee on harrys.com.
- [Connor] So for a limited time,
Harry's has an exclusive offer
for the listeners of this show.
New customers can get
the Harry's starter set
and a free body wash for just
$3 at harrys.com/trashtaste.
That's over $16 of value for just $3.
And you'll get a five blade razor
with a weighted handle,
it's actually quite weighty,
feel that gentlemen.
Foaming shave gel, a travel cover,
and a travel sized bodywash.
And I have to say, I have
used the razor myself.
It's a very clean shave.
I highly recommend it.
That gothic arch is working
wonders, might I say.
- It's that German engineering, right?
- It's an incredibly great deal,
but act fast while supplies last.
Go to harrys.com/trashtaste
to redeem your offer.
Back to the episode.
- Okay, so as the gyudon that
Connor was talking about,
I have some 7-11 gyudon right here.
- I'm not gonna lie.
It doesn't look appetizing.
- I have also never seen that before.
- Have you never seen it before?
Honestly it fucking slaps.
It tastes great.
- Show it vertically to the camera.
- Okay. I can't show it vertically.
Cause it's got, it's got
sauces in it, but look.
What happens is that it comes,
it comes with two compartments, right?
Okay. There we go.
I just hope
none of the sauce falls out.
- Oh, there's juices!
The juices!
- There's a lot of juices in here.
So what happens is it's
basically just grilled,
like what is it?
Grilled beef, beef
strips in whatever juices
they cook it in.
And it comes with two compartments.
- Ah, that is, that is hot!
- Comes with a rice compartment.
- That's a common
mistake that people make.
- Comes with a rice compartment.
- Or you could just dump it all on,
or you can just take a piece at a time.
- Yeah exactly.
You got two compartments.
You can eat it however you like.
I like to dump it on.
- I'll give a shot.
- The reason, the reason
why they split it up
is so that--
- Can we put some spices
on this bitch as well, kind of just some,
some like heat mix?
- - This is just an excuse
for us to film eating our dinners right?
- Not gonna lie,
you can tell this is like super cheap
because like it's, this
beef is half just fat.
Look at that.
Like that is...
- You know the reason
though, why they split it off
into two layers?
- That's the good part.
That's the good part.
- Oh my god.
- You know the reason why they split it up
into two layers though.
- Why?
- It's so that the rice
doesn't sog up.
- Yeah, obviously.
You wouldn't want the rice
being soggy Joey, come on.
- Honestly, if you come to
Japan, try the beef bowls.
'Cause the beef bowls are
by far my favorite like,
7-11 or whatever konbini you decide.
- Or you could go to the
top three beef bowl chains.
- Oh yeah,
or you could just go outside.
There'll probably be a Matsuya Sukiya,
or Yoshinoya right outside.
- Or Yoshinoya.
- Look at that.
It's my favorite cheap Japanese dish.
- Yo, throw some of
that on my plate, Garnt.
- So do you get this often?
- I get this whenever like
I'm traveling and I just,
you can never go wrong with beef bowls.
- If I have to get a
meal, in Lawson's right,
they basically like a katsu-don
and they have like a,
it's really fucking good.
Really clean katsu-don with just rice,
It's just like, perfect.
It's so good.
And they give you all
like a fuckton as well.
So good.
Fuck, Garnt, you really
piled that on there, eh?
- I don't know, I just...
- You do like gyudon.
- I'm more of a butadon.
- You will be the final judge
of this because you love
your beef bowls, you love your gyudons.
- I probably eat by far
the most beef bowls.
- Out of the three of us.
- Gotta get the right ratio.
I do actually like mayo with mine.
- You like mayo with your beef bowls?
- 'Cause some of the
chains will give you mayo,
and sometimes it's so
nice to have mayo with it,
I know there's some people
who think that's disgusting
but you really like,
'cause sometimes all you're getting
is just grease, grease, grease.
and Mayo helps like...
- I always get mine with Mayo.
- I mean I like the fat.
- Yeah but sometimes you need to like
mellow it out a little bit, you know?
- Yeah but this man
doesn't like condiments,
so there's no use talking to him.
- Wow, that's not bad actually.
- It's good right?
- And how much is this?
- This is 400 yen.
- Four bucks.
- This is literally, yeah,
this is about four bucks.
And you can get an entire meal.
And it fucking slaps.
- For like a one off, it
was pretty fucking good.
- [Joey] Yeah?
- Like, if you're desperate
and you want a good meal,
that's actually not bad.
I'm pretty surprised
about how good that is.
- If the gyudon man says so,
then it must be good.
- Obviously, you know, if
you go to Matsuya, Yoshinoya,
or wherever, they literally
cook it in front of you,
like, from fresh.
- This is like.
- This is not bad.
- If you're out and about, and
you just want a quick meal,
and you know, can't, there's no Matsuya,
or there's no like chain around you.
Look he's going on for seconds,
that's how good it is.
- That's that says more than anything.
- A little fatty.
But yeah, it was pretty
actually, yeah, I'd eat this.
- Would it be good for,
with some mayonnaise on it?
- Yeah.
(laughing)
Bit of mayonnaise.
That's not bad though.
- There you go.
Points to 7-11 for that one, I guess.
- Yeah so there is tons of other hot food
that we couldn't get.
And also we just don't
wanna waste all of it.
We don't want to throw away too much food.
- The staff is eating
all of it, don't worry.
So yeah.
I mean, that's most of the hot food
that we to talk about today.
And the rest is just a bunch of snacks.
- If there's one thing that all three
convenience stores have it's snacks.
- Yeah.
They have way more snacks
than they do hot food,
I think so.
- Oh way, way more.
- Alright, so before we
move on, before we move on
from the hot foods.
So how long do you guys feel
like you can survive on
convenience store food
before you start to get bored of it?
Well, I actually tried
that out once when I...
- Why?
- Because it was the only option I had.
So basically when I was--
- What do you mean it was
the only option you had?
- Well, let me explain.
When I was working, I was like 16
and I was working at the ski
fields in Hokkaido, right?
I'm in the middle of
fucking nowhere in Hokkaido.
Like in the mountains.
The only thing they had, I'm 16 as well.
So I can't drive to the next--
- And you can't afford
a fancy meal every time.
- I can't afford fancy.
So basically I'm living day by day
with what they're paying me, right?
And also because it's snowing
fucking 24/7 there, right?
Without a car you're basically fucked.
Like you can't walk into a snow storm
to like go to the next town.
- Not even your financial
advisor could save you.
- Not even my financial
advisor could save me.
But so the only thing they
had around where I was staying
was a Family Mart.
- Oh, that's why you're
a Family Mart stan.
- So I literally, throughout
that entire month.
I would want to say
minimum two meals a day
everyday for a month was Family Mart.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And you know what?
I felt like I wanted to
die by the end of it.
(Garnt laughing)
There's only so much.
Like first week, you're
just like, all right,
I'm going to try that bento,
I'm going to try that bento.
Basically. I like,
I like fully completed the Pokedex
of like, Family Mart food, right?
I was like, yeah, I tried everything.
And once I did finish
everything, I was like,
I highly regret that I did that
'cause I feel so fucking
unhealthy right now.
- 'Cause the thing is when you come,
when you come to Japan for the first time
and you see how, just how
much choice of meals there are
in every convenience store.
Especially for me coming
from England where
the only choice I have
is the Tesco's meal deal.
- Hey, come on.
Don't talk ill of like
the best thing that we
have about our country.
- But in terms of like,
let's say packageable lunches or meals
that you can get away with.
- Lunchables?
- Not even Lunchables.
- That's all I think of.
- Pastries?
That's kind of about it.
- You got sandwiches, you got...
- I think we all have, the
problem with the UK stuff
that you can like kind of take quickly.
It's all within like
the same genre of food.
There's no variety.
- Yeah, yeah.
And the thing is only say, only like
the big super mega
stores have the hot food.
Like the fresh chickens.
- The hot food is good, yeah.
- Sometimes you go to like, Sainsbury's,
it's the big Sainsbury's
and they have like the
hot rotisserie chickens.
Those actually slapped.
- Tesco's have like the sausage.
The like foot-long
sausage that you can eat.
Fucking amazing.
So good.
- But those are limited to like
the really, really big stores.
So the good thing about convenience stores
is that all this,
like everything you see
is basically homogenous
throughout basically every
convenience store you can find.
There are some that are bigger
that have even more
choice of what you can buy
but we are showcasing
stuff that you can buy in
basically every convenience
store you can get in Japan.
- I do think when you, after living here,
it's sort of like, you
view convenience food
almost like McDonald's in my mind.
Like it starts to have
like a, almost McDonald's
characteristic to the taste at
how, you know it's not like,
it's not all fresh.
It doesn't all taste quite like,
something's been a little too
like, manufactured.
- It's not as healthy
as they package it out to be.
- Right.
I mean there were definitely
some healthy things.
Like there's some decent salads,
there's some stuff like that.
And like, I mean, after
the gym, I think we always,
we always just get like,
there's just chicken breasts.
- Salad chicken, yeah.
- So they have literal--
- You have one of them, right?
One of you has one of them.
- Do I have a chicken breast?
- I think Joey might have one.
- Did you buy a chicken breast?
- No, the only thing I
have is this sausage.
(laughing)
- That's just a sausage.
- Just, it's from Johnsonville.
Amazing name for a sausage.
- I think that's
an American brand, is it?
- I think so.
- And you can just rip it open
and just start eating it, right?
It's just one sausage.
What I do have, it's not a chicken breast.
- That's it.
Something similar like that.
but they literally have a, this is this.
This is a salad chicken bar.
I don't know what a salad chicken bar is.
- [Joey] What the fuck is that?
- It's like a salad in a bar with chicken.
- No, what?
What is that shape?
No chicken has ever been in that shape.
What is that?
- It's like a chicken sausage almost.
- So normally the ones that I get,
and they also have them at
Family Mart and Lawson's,
I don't know why they
wouldn't have them at 7-11.
- It's like a salad chicken nugget.
- Imagine literally a
chicken breast seasoned.
I think the one that I always
go for is tandoori flavored.
- The tandoori one slaps.
- Chicken tandoori.
- It's literally just a chicken breast
just in a vacuum sealed
package that has just
been cooked and you just eat.
- Yeah, the vacuum seal,
vacuum seal package like this.
- Crack that bad boy open at like 3:00 AM
and it's like, really good.
- You go for a workout, right?
You know, you want to get some protein.
What's the best source of protein?
Just eat a fucking whole chicken breast.
20 grams of protein.
Boom, you're talking.
- Cause normally like,
it makes it so convenient
because no matter what mood or no matter
what kind of food you want,
they probably have it at
your convenience store.
If you want something healthy, you can...
- Oh god, that looks awful.
- This..
- That looks, oh, show
the gloss to the cameras.
- Oh my God.
(Joey cackling)
Look at that.
- Yo, give me a bite of that.
Here, let's cut that up.
- This is glossier than some nails.
Jesus Christ.
- That looks vile.
- Let me try that, let me try that.
- Where's the knife?
Ashley, get us a knife.
- [Connor] Okay, go ahead.
- Just gimme one of those.
- Oh yay, okay.
- Oh this feels.
You know what this, it feels plastic.
- I'll try it, but I'm
not going to like it.
- This looks like a hot dog
with extra peppers on it.
Honestly.
- Oh my God it tastes
like a chicken hot dog.
That's fucking weird.
- Okay, that's just a chicken hot dog.
(laughs)
- I don't know if you were supposed
to take the skin off of those though.
- No, no, no.
- It's a chicken hot dog.
I like how they call it a salad chicken
when it's just a chicken hot dog.
- Well Japan's not going to know what
a chicken hot dog is probably.
- That's fucking awful.
- Do you know what they
call corn dogs here?
- Yeah, America dogs.
- America dogs.
- I mean, honestly, that's
a pretty fucking good name.
- Yeah, it's a pretty accurate name.
- It's like, what are the hot
dogs that they eat in America?
Corn dogs.
- Alright, gentlemen.
We all have sandwiches
from our respective stores.
And I want to know which
sandwich is your go to?
- For me it's always this one.
Tuna and tamago.
- Oh fuck my bag got crushed.
But, honestly I'm not
making this look appetizing.
but same Joey!
- Yeah!
- You'll notice though,
the difference between the Family Mart
and the Lawson sandwiches with the,
especially with the egg.
- Yeah.
The egg, in Family Mart,
it kind of like.
- They actually use
sliced eggs.
- Yeah they slice the eggs,
whereas Lawson is just fully scrambled.
- And honestly, yeah, this shit slaps.
This shit is insane.
- Honestly both of them slap, I feel.
And what the fuck does Garnt have?
- They didn't have the
sandwiches I asked for,
which is just a katsu sando.
So a katsu sando is literally
just like a pork katsu.
Just with some bread slapped on the side
and some katsu sauce.
- What the fuck is,
see, I've always seen.
So show it to the camera.
So I'm always seeing this, right?
You should put it in frame
with us so that it's in frame.
- It's literally like
a strawberry shortcake
turned into a sandwich.
- That looks awful.
Can you crack that open?
- Okay, okay.
- I've always seen those
because they sell those
at Family Mart too.
I've never tried them.
Also the genius, Japanese
packaging, you just,
there's a little slip that
you pull open and boom.
It's ready to go.
Everything convenient.
- And it folds outward
like that, isn't that amazing?
That's just beautiful.
- That is Japanese engineering
to the finest level.
- And boom, you've got a little
picnic for your sandwiches.
- How do you feel about
the lack of crust, boys?
- Disgusting.
- Not gonna lie,
it's disappointing.
I mean look at this, right?
Like there's something missing.
It's the bite of the crust.
- [Joey] Yeah.
I agree.
- It's beautiful.
- I agree.
- Do you guys give a
shit if I rip some off
and hand it to you?
- Yeah, just you.
- So you try that egg
on, that's the real egg.
- Okay.
- That's the best, look at the color.
Look at the fucking bright,
the saturation has been
pumped to 10,000 on that.
You know that shit's
gonna taste good.
- This one's got
some slices in it.
- I've had this one.
Oh, that that feels like a weak bread.
You know what I mean?
- They're all weak breads,
what are you talking about?
- Oh god it's been dunked in the grease.
- Okay.
I don't know how to properly share this.
(laughs)
- Oh it's cross contaminated.
- Oh no!
- Which tamago are we trying first?
- Let's try the Family Mart one first.
- So the,
it's the one with the slices on it.
- Honestly like what I
love about Japanese eggs
is that they just have the color in them.
I don't know.
Every Japanese egg just is like,
it's like they took the egg, the egg yolk,
put it in Photoshop and
turned up the saturation.
It looks beautiful.
- It is like way too
yellow for it to be real.
- Yeah I like the egg.
The problem I have with
this sandwich, sorry.
I'm eating with my mouth.
Is the tuna tastes like shit.
- You think so?
- On this sandwich, I think so.
- I think the tuna tastes the same.
- No, you'll see what I mean, Garnt.
- Honestly, I really liked the egg.
I like the egg to be solid.
- I love the egg slices.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- I do like that.
- All right let's try the
Lawson egg sandwich then.
So this one is no egg
slices is just fully mashed.
- Okay.
What I don't like about this one and why
I've never bought this
one is because this egg
looks like runny yolk.
- No honestly, it's good try it.
- It looks like shit the
that comes out of your nose,
it's like runny egg yolk.
- Definitely a lot more of like
a mayonnaise flavor in this.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- No I prefer,
I prefer to chew on my eggs and I feel it.
- You know what?
I'll give you that one.
That like, there is
something about knowing
there's like an egg slice in that
that's way more comforting.
I don't know.
I'm going to try and fucking dissect this.
This isn't working.
- Sandwiches were just
not meant to be shared.
Let's be honest.
I'm just going to rip it off.
Sorry.
- Here you go Joey.
- Shit.
- Try some real fucking tuna
tasting sandwich action.
Give me some of that sandwich.
- Honestly, like when
it comes to the tuna,
it all tastes the same.
- No I disagree.
- What I want to mention
though is that all the breading
for all the sandwiches
in Japan, it's so fluffy.
It's so light and fluffy.
That's why it's some of my
favorite breads, I think.
- Oh my god I just realized
we're breaking bread guys.
Like true comrades.
- Which one are we eating first?
- I'm the Family Mart one.
- Okay.
- What's the difference?
- Again, there is no difference.
- No, no, no, no, I can spot which one.
That one's Lawson's.
- Okay.
- No that's Lawson's.
- I can tell the difference
Oh no actually (stammering).
- I'ma call sus on this one.
- No, no, no.
No, no, the bread.
The bread's different.
(laughing)
- The bread hit different.
- No listen, listen, try it,
you'll know what I,
shit, I should put that on the table.
You'll know what I mean.
- Honestly, Garnt.
Like you're you're the
mediator in this one.
Have both of those
and tell me if there's
a fucking difference.
- They taste different.
- Like the Family Mart one.
It's great.
- No, no, it's got a weird tinge to it.
- Let's try the Lawson one.
- Okay so this one's
the Lawson one, right?
- Yeah.
- Okay, let me try both.
- It tastes the fucking same,
oh actually hold on.
- [Connor] Yeah, see?
See what I mean?
- Lawson one's better.
- Yeah, okay, I agree.
- Right?
- The Lawson one actually
tastes like tuna.
- It's so clean.
I don't know what it is, man.
The Lawson tuna sandwich?
It's amazing.
- Like the initial taste.
I bit into both.
And the initial taste
was just like, hmm, okay.
They both taste the same.
And then the aftertaste
from the Lawson's tuna,
you actually get a taste
of tuna.
- It tastes like fish.
- Yeah, it tastes like fish.
- So if you like the taste of fish,
I'd say the Lawson one is better.
If you don't like the taste of fish,
I'd say the Family Mart one is better.
- Oh, I'll give that.
- Alright let's try the--
- Now let's try this abomination.
Honestly there's a part of me.
There's a part of me
that's thinking this is going to be good.
Although mine's contaminated with egg.
- This is my only strawberry.
- I've only got one strawberry as well.
- I've got two in mine.
- Honestly, one thing that
the sandwiches are guilty of
doing here is that they
look loaded in the front.
They look like they're filled.
And then you take one bite and you realize
there's nothing in the back.
- They clickbait you.
- Yeah.
It's literally like the
Walker's crisps where,
like you bite into it,
and most of it is just air.
- And I found that Family
Mart does that the worst.
- You think so?
- Family Mart has this
sandwich, right, that I used
to get from Family Mart,
which is egg and ham, I think.
And in the front man, it
looks like it's bursting.
It can't wait to get out,
and you take one bite.
And then you realize that
it goes from like, this.
It's so thin.
- Alright, let's give this a shot.
That's not a sandwich.
- Honestly?
- That's just a cake.
- That's just, yeah, it's a dessert.
- It's a strawberry shortcake.
- That's really fucking weird.
Cause you know what?
It tastes like a strawberry shortcake.
But then you're just chewing bread.
- Proof that bread works
with fucking anything.
- No, I, that, that tastes wrong.
- I'm not a fan of that.
- I would rather just eat
a strawberry shortcake.
- That's like the equivalent
of putting a burger
or putting a patty between two, two bread,
two bread slices, and calling it a burger.
- Yeah.
Yeah I've always seen those being sold.
Because I think they sell all of those
at like Lawson and 7-11, Family Mart.
- Yeah, they all have dessert sandwiches,
which is just fucking weird.
- I saw one with like,
I saw one where it was
like, cream and lime?
- Cream and lime?
- Not lime, sorry, kiwi, kiwi.
It was kiwi slices with like,
whipped cream.
- Kiwi and lime,
I've seen that one.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I was like, that looks fucking wack.
- One thing I will say,
the whipped cream they use here in Japan.
It's S-tier whip cream.
- I agree.
- Whipped cream to me doesn't really
fucking taste like anything.
I just kinda like--
- You taste Japanese whipped cream,
and you think it tastes like, you taste?
- I can stan that better.
I don't like whipped cream.
- You're telling me that the whipped cream
did not carry what you
just ate right there.
- Honestly the bread kind of carried it.
(laughing)
- Get out of here.
- This man I swear.
- I had like one quarter
of a fucking strawberry.
There's nothing happening.
- I used to fucking despise like
all cakes and stuff like that.
Like strawberry shortcake,
I was like, nah,
that's some boring shit,
but then I had strawberry
shortcake here and I was like,
oh my god.
- I was exactly the same.
Strawberry shortcake here blew my mind,
because the cake part is so fluffy.
- The cream, man.
- The whipped cream,
Japanese whipped cream
is the best I've tasted in the world.
- I agree.
- I will stand by that.
- I agree with that.
- And that's why Japanese
sweets tastes so good.
A lot of it is just--
- Thank you for coming to my TED Talk.
- The whipped cream.
So what are we trying next lads?
- Should we try like the
more like savory snacks?
Maybe like the fish and the meat snacks?
Do you guys have any of those?
- Sure.
So gentlemen, as you know,
one of the most well-known food items
- What was that?
- from Japan
- Was like, uh, uh.
- I was trying to figure out
what I was trying to say.
But one of the most well-known food items
from Japan is of course the jelly donut.
AKA.
- Actually you took me back
there, like wait, what?
- The onigiri.
Which if you've seen,
if you basically watch any anime,
you've seen characters eating onigiri.
- The rice balls.
- This is basically the closest we get
to an actual Japanese sandwich.
'Cause it's a rice
sandwich, basically, right?
This is a...
- Wait, whoa.
- Oh, okay.
Oh, oh, oh my God.
- What is that?
- I did not, where's the seaweed?
Where is the seaweed?
- That's like the best part.
It's like the hot dog wrapper, right?
The best part of a hot
dog is the crunch, right?
What is that?
- It is a grilled salmon onigiri.
- Oh I have a grilled salmon
one as well, from Family Mart.
- Okay we all grilled
- I also have a grilled
salmon one.
- salmon onigiri.
- So yeah, as you know, me and
Garnt actually ate onigiri,
and this is actually one
of them that I was eating,
and it was quite delicious
as much as I was complaining.
Show business.
Acting.
- Honestly, that is my
favorite onigiri to get,
from Lawson's.
- Really?
- I've never seen that one.
- What'd you mean, from Lawson's?
You mean from all of the places, Garnt.
Now Lawson's, like every
good big brain company,
has their own product line,
specifically for onigiri.
They have the basic bitch onigiri.
It's like 100 yen.
Now this is shit is like 190 yen.
- Ooh, that's the premium shit.
- Premium.
You can't even see it.
That's how premium it is.
- Honestly, I will stan 7-11
hot foods and fried foods.
I don't stan its onigiri.
- What is that?
- This is the most
depressing looking onigiri
I've ever seen.
I'm sorry.
- Look at that Joey!
- Looks like someone
put the condom on wrong.
(laughing)
- They put the condom on sideways
instead of on top.
- Now gentlemen, let me show
you what a good onigiri.
Okay actually that could--
- It looks the same!
(laughing)
- It's just a bigger condom.
- No, no, that's how it
should look, look at that.
- That's just a bigger condom.
- It's so beautiful.
- Honestly, it's beautiful,
because every bite you get,
you get a bit of seaweed in it.
It's the perfect ratio.
- Here's the thing that differentiates
between a good onigiri and bad onigiri.
It's the rice to insides ratio.
- 100% agree.
- 100% yes.
- If there's like, the
first bite you bite into
in an onigiri and you
immediately hit the inside,
that's a good onigiri.
- Yeah, to be fair, a
lot of the cheap ones,
or even sometimes like if
they've just filled it,
not quite right that one
time you do just get like
four bites in and you're
like, where is the
fucking filling?
- Where's the filling?
- I gotta ask.
Do you boys actually eat onigiri anymore?
- Yes.
- Yeah I still do.
- You do?
I gave up.
- I do whenever I need a quick,
whenever I literally need a quick snack.
- I'm just never in the
mood for a block of carbs.
You know what I mean?
That's the problem.
And like, there's not enough filling.
I'd rather just have a block of--
- Wait, you get the fucking
microwaveable goo dogs.
- That's if like, I want to fucking,
I wanna pig out.
I haven't had a goo dog in a long time.
'Cause like, that shit is just dreadful.
- Honestly, because sometimes,
sometimes I miss my lunch
and I have like a filming
or something and I just
need to fill up my stomach
as quickly as possible.
- I agree.
- And that's when I get
just like one onigiri,
that lasts me until dinner.
And it does everything it needs to do.
- What is your favorite
filling of the onigiri?
So there's different flavors
that you could have in it.
- Oh god, that's hard.
- Normally all fish, there
is sometimes grilled chicken
but honestly.
- I'm not not a fan of the
chicken breast though.
- Don't get it.
'Cause the good part about the fish one
is that normally it like seeps
into the rest of the area.
But the chicken one just
is a ball in the middle.
- I'd have to say the tuna is probably
my favorite.
- The tuna is my
favorite as well.
- Actually you are holding my favorite one
which is the salmon belly.
It's really, really good premium salmon.
In terms of the chicken.
How'd you guys feel
about the onigiri where
it doesn't really have a filling.
It's just kind of like the grilled rice
with grilled chicken or whatever.
- I used to eat those when I was little.
But as I got older, I was
like, nah, I just want,
I want something more like,
you know.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Satisfying.
- It feels like a fake,
feels like a fake meal.
I don't know why.
But yeah, I don't know why.
When I first visited Japan, I fucking,
all I had was like onigiri.
- I think everyone's like that.
- Yeah because you're like,
oh my god, I'm in Japan.
I gotta eat the Japanese things.
I can't get this at home.
I can get a sandwich at home.
But then when I started
living here, I'm like,
yo, the sandwiches are
pretty fucking bomb.
Have you tried these sandwiches?
And they're like, nearly the same price.
What am I doing, man?
And sandwiches are easier to eat.
Cause sometimes onigiri falls apart,
if you like, if you're, you know,
sometimes you're in a rush.
- If you're bad at eating it.
- Onigiri to me, I'd never
eat onigiri as a meal.
Like if I'm having a
lunch, I never pick onigiri
as the lunch.
Onigiri is a convenience
if I need to stuff myself
and have it not taste awful.
- I just realized there's
no way for us to like share.
- We've just gotta bite into it.
- It's all salmon onigiri.
- To be fair, I've never
tried the Family Mart
branded onigiri before.
- I have never tried
the Seven onigiri yet.
- I've had this one before and it's good.
And I'm just gonna do a bite
just to prove that it's good.
Again.
- Oh look at that.
Immediately.
- Okay.
How deep would I have
to bite, do you reckon,
to get the filling, Joey?
(laughing)
- I just bit a whole ton of rice,
and it didn't even have any seaweed.
I hit like one millimeter of fish though.
- Let me give a bite.
How deep, this deep?
- Mmm, I already broke into salmon.
- Yeah.
- Look at that.
- Mine, like my salmon actually has
like a little bit of like soy sauce in it.
So the soy sauce kind of seeped
into the rice a little bit.
- That's good.
- That's really flavorful.
- That's nice, fatty salmon.
- This is awful.
This is awful, I do not...
(laughing)
Honestly,
this is the most depressing
looking grilled salmon
I've ever seen.
- 7-11, fix your shit.
- Okay, so we can say
Family Mart and Lawson
have got their branded
onigiri pretty down pat.
- Yeah if you want the
best onigiri from a chain,
I would highly recommend
Lawson's.
- I would highly recommend
Lawson's as well.
Lawson's, especially the
grilled salmon belly.
That is fucking bomb.
- What other cold or savory snacks
do you guys tend to go for?
- Okay we have the...
- You don't eat that.
- I do not eat this.
You know what this is?
This is the seafood sticks that you see
in every Asian restaurant.
And I don't know why every
Asian restaurant serves these
seafood sticks.
- Look, I don't wanna make
this a dick measuring
contest, but mine's bigger.
(laughing)
Although to be fair.
I don't eat these, but every now and then,
Aki asked me to come and buy
like one of these crab sticks.
- Why?
- Okay, I tried it.
It's actually kind of good.
If you like like crab, especially.
- This isn't just like crab or fish.
This is fish paste, cheese, and cod roe.
That sounds dreadful.
- [Garnt] Oh, that sounds awful.
- My one's got like,
mayonnaise inside of it.
- Why?
- It's a seafood stick, spicy roe.
- That looks fucking awful.
- Oh my god.
- That looks disgusting.
- Look at that.
Look at that.
Oh my god.
- [Joey] I'm gonna try this.
- This is just like.
- Oh, smell it, smell it.
- Oh that smells awful.
That smells like off tuna.
- Oh it just dribbled.
- Smell that.
- Ooh.
- That does smell like
bad tuna, doesn't it?
- Ooh.
- I really don't wanna eat it.
- That is like the
fishiest fish smell ever.
- You know what, I'm not
even gonna open this,
I'm just gonna eat yours.
- You know, when you just have fish
that's been left out for a few days?
That's what this smells like.
- It smells like cat--
- The thing is, I usually
fuck with the crab sticks
at like summer festivals
and stuff like that.
So I hope this is something like that.
- That's not good.
It's just, it's bad.
- Not good, no.
- Oh god.
No, that is, that is bad.
- That's awful, that is.
I just prefer the normal crab stick.
Don't put shit in it,
don't put cheese in it.
I can't even taste the cheese.
- I don't like crab.
- I definitely taste
the cheese.
- Okay, I don't like crab sticks.
- I don't mind.
- Crab is one food
that I think just doesn't
taste good processed.
And crab sticks just feel like,
they feel like such processed food.
- It's like canned lobster,
you don't can lobster.
No one wants canned lobster.
- But you gotta have,
with the crab sticks though,
I used to think the same,
but like you go to like
a summer festival and
you get the ones that are
like on the fucking grill with
like the fucking sauce.
- Oh yeah, I bet that's
fucking good, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That shit is fire.
- Yeah but it's not,
I don't think it's the
crab that tastes good.
It's the fact that it's grilled
and it's got the sauce on it.
I'd rather have another.
- It can be good.
- I think it's really good, yeah.
- This video is sponsored by Bokksu,
Connor, what is Bokksu?
- Bokksu is the only Japanese snack box
that partners with over 100
year old family snack makers
to deliver Japan's exclusive
snacks right to your door.
And I have to say,
I've never seen any of these at a konbini.
So that probably means they're premium.
Look at this.
I love my soft cookies and this, oh, this,
I'm gonna have this later.
- Well boys.
March is the start of the hanami season.
What's hanami, Joey?
- Or the cherry blossom season in Japan,
as it's called.
- Oh, okay.
- So to commemorate that,
Bokksu orders placed in
March will get a special
hanami themed pink box instead
of Bokksu's signature orange.
But be quick because
these stocks are limited.
- [Meilyne] I'm showing the box.
- It's right here!
- [Meilyne] You can't see!
- [Connor] First time Bokksu customers
will receive the Seasons of Japan box
so they could get a taste
of the snacks per season.
- [Garnt] Repeated customers will get
a themed box every month.
Gentlemen, what kind
of snacks do you like?
- I'm a giant senbei fan.
And this is a rather
extraordinary looking senbei.
- That's the black Sesame
taiko with the kumamon design.
- I love me some sesame.
So I'm very down.
- What do you got there Garnt?
- I have here a cookie.
Joey, what is this cookie?
- Oh, that's the aomuri
apple caramel yakkoi sable.
- Damn, that sounds sexy.
- Aomori is famous
for their apples, right?
- All I know is I like me
my soft cookies, and this?
- That looks so good.
- This is a nice soft moist cookie.
- God I want a cup of tea.
- Best part is, it's vegetarian.
- Ooh!
- Joey, what's yours?
- Well, my favorite one is the
stick potato supamucho plum.
We talked about the sour
plums on this episode.
- Yeah.
- So you know me.
I love me my sour plums.
So if there's a sour plum snack,
you know I'm gonna dig that.
- Ooh, that looks nice.
And gentlemen I'm sure we can all agree
that ever since moving to Japan,
Japan's snack game is
just on another level.
- Oh yeah, there's no competing with it.
- No one can travel at the moment,
but if you want a taste of Japan
and all their glorious snacks,
you can do that by
getting yourself a Bokksu.
- [Joey] Bokksu honors Japanese heritage
and artisinal makers
by partnering with them
to bring authentic flavors
around the world.
- So get 10% off, Save up to $47
on your own authentic
Japanese snack box from Bokksu
using our link.
- [Garnt] Be sure to use code
trashtaste10 for 10% off.
- Back to the video.
- What'd you got there Conner?
What do you got there Conner?
- This is a rather odd looking.
It's like a fucking whole deli.
- Yes, it's just a bunch of
cuts of bacon, it looks like,
but like, sausages.
- We're about to show
off why Japanese bacon
is just one of the worst bacons
you can find in the world.
- I'll try my best to hold this up
without burning myself.
- Okay, so this is Japanese bacon here.
- This is a meat platter.
- And as you can see,
it is floppy and soggy.
- Oh god, oh god.
- Don't flop it around!
Hold still.
- I just want to show off
that this is not what bacon
should look like or feel like.
- This is two kinds of
sausage and pepper bacon.
- I mean, what are we trying?
- Well, I'll, you know, I'll
try the one kind of sausage.
- I'll try the other kind then.
Whatever one is--
- Should we just cut one in half actually?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But what else do you have
there in the meantime Joey,
while I prepare this?
- Okay, well I know you guys
have never tried this but
we have Nankone.
Shiu nonkone, which is pickled plums.
- Pickled plums.
You think I haven't tried that,
I actually have tried that.
- Okay, but there's two different types.
- Because, for some reason,
Sidney fucking loves pickled plums.
And I do not know why.
- Here's the thing.
Literally, I dunno if
this is just a stereotype,
literally every female I
know loves pickled plums.
I don't know why.
Like if it's plum, if
it's like an actual plum,
plum flavored things.
- Meilyne it true?
- Meilyne, do you like pickled plum?
- Yeah!
(laughing)
That's what I'm saying!
Chicks love pickled plums.
I don't understand.
Literally every Japanese girl I know loves
pickle plum flavored shit.
- Alright boys.
Tell me what kinds of sausage
you would like to have.
- Just give me one of them.
- What are the different,
I mean, this just--
- It looks like a finger.
(laughing)
- It's basically, they call--
- It's like straight up a finger, look!
(laughing)
It looks like a finger!
- That's like fucking out of Yoshikage,
that's out of Kira's collection, man!
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yoshikage Kira's collection.
- That's one thing that Japan
just doesn't do and it's sausages.
Like they just don't do them, right?
And like, they'll they'll go
around calling this chorizo.
Like that's what they, in restaurants.
- That is not chorizo.
- They will call this chorizo.
And it's a joke.
I mean it's literally a hot dog.
- I mean, it's just a sausage, eh?
- Just a hot dog.
- It's just a sad frankfurt.
That's what it is.
- You can palate cleanse
though with a kitsunanko...
- They don't need to see this.
- Let me try the bacon.
Yeah it's shit.
- Here, I'll give you
guys the pickled plums
'Cause we have three.
- Okay, so this is actually something new.
They, you know, I'm sure
the viewers watching,
they've tasted bacon before.
They've tasted sausages.
They've tasted hot dogs.
What they haven't tasted pickled plums.
- So Japan is like kind of known
for its pickled plum.
Umeboshi it's called.
- Yeah, umeboshi.
- But basically there's
two types of umeboshi.
There's the really, really
sour types of umeboshi
that you find--
- That's the only one I've had.
- This is the sweet umeboshi.
- Sweet umeboshi?
- Yes, this amakachu umeboshi.
- This one too?
- Yes, yeah.
these are all the same.
- So this is the sour one.
- No these are the sweet ones.
These are all sweet.
- Oh, okay.
- Yeah.
- I'll try it.
- It's a slightly salted sweet umeboshi.
- Oh shit, it's dripping everywhere.
- Yeah, watch out.
- Okay. let me taste this.
- I know you guys
haven't tried this, but--
- Why does it look like
a deflated scrotum?
(laughing)
- Because it's been,
because it's been dried basically.
What do you think?
- I'm not a fan.
I'm still not a fan.
- So what'd you do,
just take a big bite?
- [Joey] Yeah, there's a seed inside of it
so watch out.
- Watch out for the seed.
- Oh!
(laughing)
It's so sour!
- Really?
This is the sweet one.
- This is the sweet one.
- This is sweet?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- In what universe is this sweet?
- Yeah, this is the sweet one.
- So if you have the sour
one, it's literally like...
What's the most sour thing you
can normally get in like...
- Sour Patch Kids.
- It's way more sour than that.
- You know that one video
we did with Joey's channel
where we had to, the powdered sour.
It just tastes like a bite of that.
- Yeah, that's basically pickled plum.
- Yeah it's like, there's,
I bought this thing for my channel
which is pure umeboshi extract.
And it's considered one of the most
sour things in the world.
- That's fucking awful.
- Yeah.
It's basically you start
salivating immediately.
It's one of the most sour things
you can just naturally get.
- It was really good.
My grandma used to hand make these.
So that's why I have a special
thing for them.
- I do think there was
a lot at play of like,
I am not used to these foods.
And although I'm more than
happy to try every single item.
It doesn't mean I have to
like every single item.
- No of course not.
- What I don't understand
about pickled plums.
Is that why'd you like
eating something that sour?
Like it's so sour, it's more
sour than any kind of sweet
or any kind of.
- I don't know.
Like I used to like, cause
again, like my grandma
used to like hand-make the
umeboshi, and would just
send it in tupperware, right?
And it's like, it is the
most sour shit imaginable.
I used to just come home
- If I had a Japanese grandma
that made it for me,
I'm sure I'd love the
fuck out of it, right?
- I would just come home after school
and just get the tupperware
and just fucking eat it.
- That's got love in it Joey.
That didn't have love.
That had factories and suffering.
That tastes like shit.
- My grandma's umeboshi's the best.
- Did you mouth just look like this?
- Oh yeah, all the time,
but I fucking loved it.
- 'Cause that's me after
one bite of eating umeboshi.
- Yeah.
I dunno, I love it.
- Another item that you
can get that, you know,
you won't really find
elsewhere in the world probably
is a lot of dried fish items
that are like snackable.
- Yeah.
- So Garnt has some...
- I have some squid and
seaweed tempura chips.
- So tempura is a kind of light batter.
- It's a light batter
for frying, yeah.
- For frying.
- I have salmon skin chips, which,
they really didn't do good
with a good name there.
- I kind of fuck with these.
- No, no.
I like these.
I also really fucking love
all of the squid stuff.
Like fried squid.
What's the other one?
- The dried squid?
- Dried squid as well I like.
They have like a certain
type of frying technique
for some of the squids
that are really good.
- Yeah.
- It looks fucking vile
when you pull this out of
the package, like octopus,
it looks so gross.
But it's pretty good.
So should we bust some of these open?
- Yeah, let's try them out.
- I don't think I have any.
- Joey, you wanna have,
oh actually you know what?
Wow, they look like crisps.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So these are designed to
basically look like fish crisps.
Right?
- That's crazy.
That's kind of epic.
- That's kinda epic.
- That's an epic gamer moment right there.
- Look at that.
- So I'll hold one up, right?
- So, look at that.
That could be like a square.
Do you have squares in Australia?
They're British crisps.
- No I don't think so.
- They look exactly like this, don't they?
Wow.
- But they also,
I mean they smell like
you think they smell.
It's a very fishy smell that
they smell like, obviously.
'Cause it's fish.
- That's good, I like that.
With a beer?
- With a beer, oh, we'll do it.
With a beer, cheers boys.
- Cheers, gentlemen.
(can opening)
Mmm.
That's great.
I love that.
I feel like I just
worked a hard day fishing
in the middle of nowhere in Aomori.
You know what I mean?
Like it takes me back.
Honestly, these taste so good with beers.
I just kind of want to keep eating these.
- Yo, give me one.
- Give me one of those.
- Let's try one of these.
Try one of these.
- I don't think I've
tried these, actually.
- These have a bit more bite to them.
- Ooh!
Yo!
That's good!
- They've got some texture
to them, don't they?
- Yeah.
That's like the unhealthier
version of this, I suppose.
- 'Cause this, it's basically,
this is basically that
with a bit more batter.
So you've got a bit more of a bite.
- I think I might prefer these ones.
- Those are nice.
These have a nice crunch to them.
- I'm having another one, man.
- Oh.
- Let me bring out a snack that
another snack that I'm sure
you guys have probably never
seen or heard of before.
- [Garnt] Okay.
- I'm glad that,
I'm glad that Ashley brought them.
It's kaninto.
- What is that?
- Ah, I did buy these one time.
I thought they were chocolate.
- Yeah.
- They weren't chocolate.
- Most people will look at
this and go, oh look,
it's actual pieces of turd.
- I thought it was chocolate,
I was so hype to dig in!
- What is it?
- Basically it is black sugar particles.
But when you pull it out.
- Black sugar particles?
- Really selling me on this.
- It's like fried black sugar right?
I'm pretty sure that's what it is.
- That sounds like a physics term.
- But when you pull it out,
it straight up just looks like a turd.
- Okay.
(laughing)
- I don't know what to tell you.
- That's a very fancy
name for a turd there.
- That looks Brian Griffin's poop.
- [Joey] There you go.
- What is this?
- You know what that looks,
you know what this looks like?
This looks like a turd that
like a Pomeranian would do.
Cheers?
- Like a small dog.
- Cheers?
- Cheers.
(crunching)
- You know what?
That ain't bad.
- Yeah, right?
- It just tastes like--
- Sugar with air.
It's just sugar.
- It just tastes like a crisp sugar.
- Yeah.
It's basically just deep fried sugar.
- I honestly don't really like that.
- [Joey] Really?
It's a, black sugar is
kind of a hit or miss
with a lot of people.
- It's a miss.
- I mean, okay.
So the thing is I couldn't
eat a whole packet of these.
I chomp on one of these,
I'm like, that was nice.
Am I, am I getting a
craving to go for one more?
Nope.
One's enough for me.
- Wait, what, what is
this in Japanese again?
- This is called kokto karinto.
- What a fucking name.
- Kokto is black sugar,
karinto is like the name
of the actual snack.
- How unhealthy is it to
just eat the entire thing?
- What's the calories on that one?
- Calories?
698.
(laughs)
- Per how many grams?
- For the whole bag.
135 grams.
- Fucking hell.
How much sugar is in that bitch?
- I mean, you're just eating pure sugar.
- No, no, no, no, wait.
- 37 grams.
- Wait, that's way less than I expected.
- I mean, it just feels like
you're eating fried sugar.
- There's actually more carbs in this,
there's 81 grams of carbs.
- Holy fuck.
- What?
Okay.
- There's seven grams of
protein in this thing.
- Oh well great, after a workout.
- Yeah perfect for after a workout.
- Where's the protein coming from?
- I have no idea.
- Where the fuck is the
protein coming from?
- I have no idea.
- They're literally making
protein out of thin air here.
- Japan be doing that.
Did they just put like a
bit of protein powder in it?
- Yeah, pretty much.
- Just like balance it out.
- We're going to make
this healthy somehow.
- Exactly.
- Shall we get out something else?
- A giant bag full of things now,
these are more like, I
guess sweets or kind of.
- Should we just dump
the rest on the table
and see what we got?
All right.
Look at all that.
- Holy fuck I have a lot
more than you guys.
- Let's see what Santa
brought us.
- I have way more
than I think you guys do.
- What is that that you bought?
- So many, what the fuck?
- I do have that.
- So many sweets there.
- Alright.
Should I just start with the
stuff that looks interesting?
Okay first of all, one of
my favorite Japanese snacks.
it's gotta be top, it's top
tier for me, this is S-tier.
- Mochi senbei?
- Senbei in general.
- Oh yeah, senbei in general.
- Not mochi, but senbei in general,
there's a senbei store
not too far from us.
I go there like every week to get my
weekly supply of senbei.
- Yeah, I do as well.
It's so good.
- Oh fuck, senbei is so good.
If you don't know it's
like a rice cracker.
But it's basically like,
it doesn't feel too heavy.
And you can have like one or two
and you feel like really satisfied.
It's not too bad for you either.
- I mean it is just like, rice.
- It feels like a crisp.
But just lighter.
And for some reason it's more filling
than a single crisp.
- Oh yeah, an entire packet of senbei
is like a meal.
- So this is mochi,
oh my god, whoa, this has
a funky texture to it.
- Okay.
- What the fuck?
- Is it soft?
- Yeah, it's like a soft cookie,
a soft baked senbei.
- Woo, okay, is it chewy?
It looks chewy.
- Oh my god.
- What is that?
Okay.
- This is, yeah, so mochi senbei
is kind of in the same.
So there's different types.
There's hard senbei and
then there's soft senbei.
- There's hard senbei,
and then there's rock
fucking solid senbei.
There are some senbei where
I've had, there was one,
there was like, it was like
yuzu pepper or something.
And I was like oh, that sounds amazing.
So I order it, right?
And I fucking like,
break my teeth I swear,
biting on this shit.
- What is it like a jawbreaker
kind of senbei?
- Honestly, there's like,
there's the perfect
hardness which is just,
cracks immediately upon...
- It's like a rice cracker.
- Right, that's what you want.
- And then some of them it just feels like
you're biting into a stone.
- That's pretty weird.
Huh.
- If this was a cookie,
I would think this is the
perfect kind of texture
I'm looking for in a cookie.
- There's actually one
more level above this
called nure senbei which
literally means wet senbei.
And it's like actually like wet.
But they make it for old
people who can't like,
break into it.
- Aww.
That's wholesome, okay.
Let's give it a shot.
- Okay.
- What the fuck?
Whoa, that's weird.
- Yeah, so mochi rice
is actually different
from regular rice.
Mochi rice is a lot softer
and a lot more like squishier.
So you get something like this, yeah,
it's a little wack aint it?
- Whoa, that's so bizarre!
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I don't like it.
- You know what it is?
It's moist.
- To explain--
- Why's Meilyne laughing,
what's funny Meilyne?
- [Meilyne] I just love Garnt's reaction.
- Oh.
- To explain what I just experienced.
So as we said,
this has the perfect texture
for like a good cookie.
And like my experience has
told me that this is good.
I'm going to bite into this
and it's going to taste sweet.
And what I tasted was a salted cracker
with a moist cookie texture.
- It isn't bad though.
I'd eat it.
Like I wouldn't search
for it, but I'd eat it.
- That, that was,
that texture and taste just
doesn't belong together.
I don't know, something about that.
- You've kind of been conditioned, right?
- Maybe so.
Cause I, taste it and it tastes good.
And I feel the texture and
the texture feels good.
but together it just does
not synergize at all.
It's like anti umami, man.
- It's like a plus and
a minus put together.
- Well, it looks like you
have a senbei there. Garnt.
A big boy senbei.
- I have a proper senbei.
- That's a kabukiage.
This is my favorite type of senbei.
Kabukiage.
- Fucking hell Garnt.
Fucking--
- Yeah, Jesus.
- I just wanted to try how hard it is.
- We actually have the smaller kabukiage.
These ones I buy quite regularly.
- These ones, I like these.
But when you have like four or
five, you start to feel sick.
- Oh yeah.
- 'Cause they're so like,
what's the word to
describe, maybe just fat.
(crunching)
- These are really good.
- Yeah.
- So there it's like, how
would you describe the texture?
It's...
- Cavernous.
- It's like The Thing from
fantastic four, isn't it?
(laughing)
- It kinda does.
- I don't know what it
is that's like amazing
for like one or two bites,
but really like sickly after like three.
You know what I mean?
- I dunno, man.
I could destroy a whole packet of these.
- Maybe it's just me,
it's gotta be just me.
This is not bad though.
- These are my favorite
types of senbeis I think.
- So this tastes exactly the
same as what we just had.
but this is the texture I
imagine that taste having.
It's just like, it's a nice salty cracker
just with a bit more air in between.
Or like it's, it's fatter than the cracker
but it's lighter than the cracker.
It's kind of like eating card and foam.
(laughing)
Just like flavored.
- Alright Joey, what are
we having from yours?
- Okay, so I've never
actually seen this before.
- The fuck is that?
- But I know this brand, Baby Star Ramen.
- That looks like a ramen.
- Baby Star Ramen is like,
yeah it is.
So basically Baby Star Ramen is like,
the kind of really, what's the word?
It's like the dried out ramen?
- Oh is it the instant ramen?
- It's like the instant
ramen looking things
but it's in a snack form.
And I guess this is like
the mazesoba flavored one.
Which I've never seen before.
- Crank that bitch up.
So you just eat it dry?
- Oh look at that, it's like...
- What the fuck?
- It's like little snacks.
It's literally tiny instant ramen.
- Oh my God.
That looks next level.
I need to try this, here you go.
- You know, I hate this
is my first concern
but this just cannot be even
remotely healthy, right?
- Of course it's not healthy.
It's literally fried
instant ramen noodles.
- It's fine.
- I kinda like it.
- Okay.
I dunno if you did the
same thing, but as a child.
Sometimes you would,
sometimes I would take instant ramen
like hardened instant ramen,
and just kind of like smash
it up into little pieces,
put the like, the seasoning
on it and just eat it
like it was like a snack.
- We had a brand of that,
it's called Mami noodles.
They would actually sell
packets of that shit.
It was the best.
- What are you in prison?
What do you do that for?
- Because it tastes
fucking great, fuck off.
- Ashley, you know Mami noodles, right?
- [Ashley] I did the same
thing when I was young.
- Yeah, right!
- Yeah, exactly.
- Have you never had
like, the ramen seasoning,
or the instant noodle seasoning?
- No.
- It tastes fucking bomb.
It's like putting the seasoning off--
- It's like MSG.
It's like pure MSG.
- Pure MSG.
- Alright, now I'm salty.
- Ask a kid I was told to never do that
because it's unhealthy as fuck, but.
- But I guess someone
grew up and was like,
I can make a product out of that.
- This literally tastes like childhood.
It tastes like every Asian childhood.
- It's got a little spice to it too,
which is nice.
- Ooh, okay.
- [Meilyne] So good on salad.
- It's so good on salad.
- On salad?
- You mean croutons?
They're not croutons.
- Yeah they're not croutons.
They do look like croutons.
- They kind of look like croutons.
- It's like a Japanese crouton.
- What is this?
- Watashi no, what is that?
- Karashi?
- Karashi, what is that?
- That's mustard.
- What is this?
- I don't actually know
what it is.
- Crack it open.
- Yeah, let's crack it open.
- This is from Lawson's.
I don't know what it is.
Our intern just bought it.
- [Ashley] I have no
idea what it is either.
- [Connor] What is that?
- That just looks like
a potato chip I guess.
- [Connor] What the fuck?
- Oh my god, that has a kick to it.
- There we go.
- [Joey] Wow.
- Oh my god.
- [Joey] That has a kick.
- Okay.
I'm not a fan.
- Yeah, you don't like condiments.
(laughing)
This is like condiments in a snack.
- It tastes like mayo and
mustard in like a crisp.
That's so weird.
- I actually kind of fuck with it.
- It's fucking horrible.
What the fuck is wrong with you guys?
Condiments.
Condiments are meant to be, you know,
are meant to enhance food.
They're not meant to be the food.
I literally just ate.
I literally just ate
hardened mustard and mayo.
- I actually kinda like that.
Yeah, it's actually kind good eh?
It has a really strong
like mustard kick to it.
- So I'll pick another one.
Cause I have too many.
What looks interesting?
That's, we literally just
have these in the UK.
- Yeah, that's fine.
- What are those?
- What's this?
Biscuits?
- Oh yeah, the cream sandwiches.
The custard creams?
Custard cream biscuits?
That's what they look like.
This is cognac chip seaweed and salt.
Konyaku?
- Yeah, Konyaku.
Low in calories, Natural Lawson's, okay.
- Okay.
- Should we give it a shot?
- Konyaku does have zero calories, so.
- Well, well, well, gamers,
let's give it a shot.
Garnt, go ahead.
- Thank you very much.
- Go ahead.
- [Garnt] Look at that.
- That looks healthy.
I don't know if that's a good comment.
I can literally see through it.
That's how you know how healthy it is.
- Okay it doesn't taste like anything.
That is the most inoffensive thing ever.
- That tastes like air with
like a hint of seaweed.
- Try these, try these.
- The moment like moisture hits it,
it just dissolves and disappears.
- That was literally like eating nothing.
- You know what it was?
A Rice Krispie if it had
been scaled up in size,
but not with like the added ingredients
needed to scale it up.
- It's literally just going
into Photoshop and going.
(laughing)
- Have you seen that video on the internet
where someone manages
to like, deep fry water?
- What?
- Yeah, someone managed to deep fry water.
Like a packet of water.
That's what I imagine that tastes like.
- Why would they do that?
- Alright, I've got here, Castella.
- I fucking love these.
I don't know what Castella is.
- Oh Castella, that's a
specific type of Japanese--
- Because normally it's in like a block.
- It's like a block, yeah.
- Which country is Castella from?
- Look it up.
- What is Castella?
- Do you want to explain what it is?
- We'll find out.
- [Ashley] I did buy one, Castella.
- Okay.
- Castella's like a cake of kinds, right?
Or it's like a pastry?
- Okay it looks like a pastry.
- It's really fucking good.
- [Meilyne] Japan made it.
- Is it really?
- [Meilyne] Developed in Japan.
- Okay, so it's made in Japan,
looks like a little pastry.
- Dude it's good, try it.
- It's like a cream puff.
- Okay, let me.
- Mmm.
- Okay, that's good.
That is fucking good.
- [Meilyne] Imported, but Spanish made.
- Spanish.
- Spanish, I thought so.
- Mmm!
- [Ashley] Portuguese.
- [Meilyne] Portugal.
- Portugal.
- Is that nice or not?
That is a nice clean cake.
- That is fucking nice.
One thing I've noticed about
the pastry here that I love.
Everything is fluffy as fuck.
- Yeah, so fluffy.
- I love--
- Yo, give me another one of those.
Those are fucking great.
You guys want a Castella?
- Like from the shortcake, to the bread,
to the whipped cream,
to the fucking Castella.
Everything is so fluffy.
- Soft and fluffy.
(moans)
- I saw a bit just fucking.
- Which is why it's so
easy to eat sweets here,
because they find a different way
to market different kind of sweets,
and they all taste fucking amazing.
You really can't go wrong with sweets.
- Well I'm gonna try something
from the Family Mart collection.
- Whoa, is that an Italian import?
What is that?
- It's using proper Italian caramel sauce.
Caramel popcorn.
- Isn't caramel just sugar?
- It's literally just fried sugar.
(laughing)
- But like, I won't lie.
One thing as I've said in the past before,
with the movie theaters.
I have been very impressed
with popcorn in Japan.
They have really taken popcorn.
- I'm not a huge fan of
popcorn, but lemme try.
- Honestly, Japanese
popcorn, if you come here,
it's fucking good, yeah?
You think popcorn is
like, an American staple,
like it's good shit.
- I actually like that,
that's not too sweet.
- That is just popcorn.
I don't know.
I don't really care about popcorn.
- Go to a movie theater in Japan.
Make sure you get popcorn.
Get the half and half.
You won't be disappointed.
- The thing about popcorn to me is that
I'm never the one to buy popcorn.
But I'll always take
it if someone's got it.
- I'm always that guy.
- Like I never go out of
my way to be like, okay,
I am craving popcorn now,
I need popcorn.
I'm more just the guy who's just like,
okay, there's popcorn?
I mean I'm gonna take some.
If it's there, but I'm never gonna
go out of my way.
- Like I'll never order
my own popcorn at a theater,
but if someone has popcorn, I'm taking it.
- Exactly.
If I'm offered I'm not gonna say no.
- I just read what this is called.
- What?
- This is the most unappetizing name
I've ever heard in my life.
- [Joey] Go on.
- Okay.
- Sugar Rusk.
Is the English name.
- Rusk?
- And it's actually in
Japanese as shuga rasshu.
- Shugarasku.
- Are you sure they didn't like,
just try to spell out Sugar Rush,
and just kind of fucked it up?
- I'm having a shugarasku!
- Where's the Fortnite chug jug?
- Wow, look at that.
- What is it?
Let me take one.
What is, okay.
I look at this.
- Mini baguette.
- I look at this and I'm like,
this should not taste sweet.
If I bite into this and it tastes sweet.
- This is like those like party baguettes
where you put like a little bit of like,
salmon on top of it.
- Yeah, yeah, you put a little salmon,
you put a little bit of mozzarella cheese.
- Ooh la la.
- Like at a fancy house party.
(crunching)
- Why?
- Oh, but it's really sweet.
It's literally sugar on a baguette.
- It's sugar on a baguette.
- Nope, nope.
Nope.
- That's fucked up.
Let's get that out of here.
- I'm noping,
I'm noping the fuck out of there.
- Get it the fuck out of here.
- That is like, going against like,
- That's fucking awful.
- everything that France fought for.
(Garnt laughs)
- They did not have the French Revolution
so this could happen.
- Yeah, exactly.
- That's, oh god.
- To help us out.
Lawson's has a collaboration with,
how do you pronounce this?
Godiva?
- Godiva?
- Is it Godiva or Godiva?
- I think it's Godiva, right?
- [Ashley] Godiva.
- No one knows?
- It's Godiva.
- So they have like their own
collection of like, chocolate.
And I'm not gonna lie.
It looks fucking sexy.
- Honestly any time they have,
so Family Mart or Lawson's.
- Wait.
Gimme that?
- What is it called?
- That's fucking curry bread.
- Oh, what?
- It's kare pan.
- Is that curry bread?
- It's curry bread.
- Oh no.
Oh no.
- This is chocolate bread.
- This is beef curry
bread in a chocolate bun.
- Yo crack that open,
let's give it a shot.
Let's give it a shot.
- Oh I gotta try this.
- Okay, okay.
This is gonna be a Trash Taste first here.
- Why?
- Because I have literally never--
- Oh my god,
yo, show it to the camera.
- Oh my god!
- Pull it out.
- What is that?
- That's...
That looks like a donut!
- It looks like curry bread, but, with,
if it's like made out of chocolate.
- Open up a napkin, rip that shit open.
- So to explain what curry
bread is normally like,
it's literally, you take Japanese curry.
And then you deep fry it in katsu, right?
Katsu bread, and then,
it's kind of like a jelly filled donut,
except, imagine the filling was curry.
- And it's fucking good.
- Normal curry bread is fucking amazing.
This is not normal curry bread.
- This is
an abomination.
- I'm excited to,
I'm actually excited, 'cause I
- I'm kind of interested.
wanna know what the fuck has gone wrong.
- Like how is the synergy
of chocolate and curry
gonna mix?
- If I like this, what
does it say about me?
- I will say for experience points.
One of the worst combinations I've had
was when I went to this
Wisconsin state fair, in the USA.
And they were selling chocolate bacon.
They would literally take bacon,
and dip it in chocolate.
- That ain't it.
- I'm about to find out if
there is a worse combination
right now than chocolate bacon.
- I don't know man,
chocolate bacon sounds fucking horrible.
- Okay.
Well chocolate curry bread?
That also sounds horrible.
- Alright.
- Oh, okay, look at that.
So from the looks of it,
it literally looks like curry
in between chocolate bread.
- That smells like,
just a contradiction.
Let's give it a bite.
Let's bite into it, boys.
Oh that's fucked up.
That's fucked up.
That ain't right.
- No.
- I don't like that.
- Oh.
- Do you like that, Joey?
- I kinda like it.
- No!
- Wait.
- No.
- That's awful.
That was awful, that's awful.
- That is so awful, oh my god.
Oh my god.
- I don't know if I'm just fucked up,
but that just tastes
like curry bread to me.
- No it tastes, what
are you talking about?
- I legitimately can't
taste the chocolate.
- I can't taste the chocolate.
All I get is like a
weird bitter after tone.
- It's even worse than chocolate bread
because it's not even sweet.
It's the, you can taste
the cocoa in the chocolate.
And then you bite into
it and then you get a
mouthful of curry.
It's the worst.
It's an aftertaste that you, ugh.
- I like legitimately can't
taste the chocolate at all.
- You taste the cocoa though, right?
- No.
- I bet with this one,
it's gonna be rich.
This is the chocolate bread,
and it's their collaboration with Godiva.
- Oh god, get that away from me.
That literally felt...
- To me, that just tastes
like a curry bread.
So I liked it.
- Oh ho ho.
- Oh ho!
- Now that
- That looks good.
- is a heart attack.
(laughing)
That is a heart attack
in a piece of bread.
- Did you get a whiff of that?
- Yeah.
- That was heavy chocolate.
- That's how chocolate should look like.
Chocolate bread, yes please.
- Dude, I get like a nosebleed
after eating one piece
of Godiva chocolate,
let alone this whole fucking bread.
- The chocolate bread which actually,
looks pretty fucking good.
- Oh yeah that looks good.
- That looks very good.
- But that's because
they're not being adventurous
with fucking curry bread.
- Look, if there's one
thing you shouldn't put
in chocolate bread, it's curry.
- Here's a nice cross section.
We've got some
chocolate paste here.
- Oh god, that is very strong.
- Chocolate paste on chocolate bread.
- It smells like heaven.
- Just took a wish.
A whiff, sorry.
- Oh, that's...
- [Siri] Chocolate is
spelled C-H-O-C-O-L...
(stifled laughing)
- Okay, that's really good.
- Honestly?
A little disappointed.
- Really?
- Okay, no.
No.
- You don't like that?
I really like it.
- The chocolate tastes very artificial.
- The chocolate tastes good.
I don't like the bread.
That tastes not as good as I,
It's chewy bread as well.
It's not the fluffy bread.
- I like the chewy bread.
- Chewy bread doesn't taste good
with the chocolate they put in there.
- I'd fuck with it.
- Joey, you fuck with anything, Joey.
- Joey's like, is that fucking weird?
I'd fuck with it.
- Is this seasoned vomit?
I mean, I'ma try it.
Okay, I'd fuck with that.
I'd fuck with that.
- I'm the kind of guy who's like,
I don't wanna offend anyone.
So if I went to another
country and they're like,
oh, this is what we eat.
And it's just vomit with seasoning.
I'd be like, well, I mean,
I don't wanna offend anyone.
So I'll give it a shot.
And I'd be like, it's great.
- Yeah, you don't have to like it at all.
- Yeah, just trying it.
- Just trying it I think
is more of an appreciation to the culture
than anything else.
- What was presented here
was a massive disappointment
from the usual kind of Godiva.
- It looks like sex.
Right?
This looks like sex.
Tastes like it should
be like fucking amazing.
And how many calories is this bad boy?
254 calories.
31 grams of sugar.
Oh carbohydrates, and 29 grams of sugar.
- Damn.
The black sugar poop pieces
were less healthier than that.
- Yeah I know.
And I've got here some almond cookies?
- Yo, okay, I'd fuck with that.
- But in Japanese it's
called almond balls.
(laughing)
- Wait, why do they look like that?
What's with the?
- I don't know.
They don't look like cookies.
- They look like bonbons.
- Yeah they look like
fucking bonbons, don't they?
Okay let's...
- I do fuck with anything
that has almonds in it.
- I'm just getting so full.
- Almonds are easily my
favorite kind of nut.
- Oh that's kind of nice.
- Yeah, almond is a good nut.
- Almond is like...
- Top tier.
- One of the top tier nuts.
- S-tier nut.
- If we were gonna like, tier
the nuts, almonds up there.
- Alright let's give it a shot boys.
Whoa.
That was weird.
- It's got this, covered in powder sugar.
- Okay.
So I thought, I don't know why I thought
it was gonna be soft on the inside.
It wasn't.
It's just shortbread.
- You know what this tastes like?
It tastes like something
you'd buy in Hawaii.
You know what I mean?
It's like, very like--
- But why Hawaii?
- It tastes like
somewhere you'd go to like
a food festival.
And they're like, here's
our new weird thing.
We mash up almonds, put them in a bowl,
and put sugar on them, it's like,
I mean, yeah, sure.
- I don't know, it tastes very like,
kind of like tropical.
- It's good.
- No, no, no.
- It's good, but like, why?
Just eat an almond, you know what I mean?
- It just tastes like shortbread
with a bit of almond in there.
- That's true, yeah.
Bang on, that's spot on, actually.
- Yeah it's shortbread with almond
and some frosting inside.
- I think that's literally,
- Wanna try, Meilyne?
- You literally just
described what it was.
- I just described it as a whole.
- That's okay.
I mean that's, you know.
- It's okay.
- I'm not gonna go and
buy that, but I'll eat it.
- Now we are getting to the point where
you might recognize some of these brands.
So I've got here some Kit-Kat.
- Is that sweet potato?
- What is this flavor?
- That's sweet potato, right?
- That's beni imo, which is
like red potato, I think?
- I think it's called taro in English.
- You always--
- It's just sweet potato, okay.
- This is sweet potato Kit-Kat.
- Whenever you see this
paste or this color,
it's always sweet potato,
I've learned in Japan.
They love it.
They put it on everything.
- Honestly, sweet potato
kinda slaps, but...
- Whoa.
- Whew, okay.
- Hello.
- It's a ball of Kit-Kat.
- It's a Kit-Kat ball.
- Bite that in half,
let me get a cross section going on.
(laughs)
Okay it's like wafer.
Yeah it's good.
- Yeah.
- I would eat that.
- You can't go wrong
with a Kit-Kat I find.
- I feel like this is just a Kit-Kat.
- It is.
- No I mean.
- It's literally just,
they took a Kit-Kat
and they went (grunts).
- Honestly?
I would say that tastes
better than a Kit-Kat.
- I'd prefer that over a regular Kit-Kat.
- Yeah.
I would say.
- Is that one or one bag?
- One bag.
- I was gonna say.
- 244 calories for one ball?
(laughs)
- I was like, oh my god.
- Holy shit!
- I'm gonna go to the toilet right now.
- All three of us would've
had a heart attack.
- Oh my god, I was getting scared there,
I was like, why does this taste so good?
- Alright, I got, I've
never seen these before.
- Ahh.
- Some fancy shit.
- Smokey Pretz.
- Yeah, Pretz, this is smoked
potato butter flavored.
- Smoked potato butter!
- Smoked potato butter.
- Pretz are just like basically...
- Savory Pocky.
- Yeah, (babbles) I'm
losing words right now.
Savory Pocky.
- I prefer Pretz over Pocky, personally.
- I mean they're savory.
- If you go to the supermarket,
you'll see that flavor,
and you'll always see the pizza flavor
which they have.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So they have pizza flavored sticks.
Just eat a fucking pizza.
- Just eat a pizza.
- Pizza shouldn't be a flavor.
'Cause there's different flavors of pizza,
so what is pizza flavor?
- I quite like that.
- I like that.
- I hate that I like that.
- You can never go wrong
with Pretz, honestly.
If you're looking for a savory snack,
Pretz is the way to go.
- Oh that aftertaste is gross.
I'm getting really bad
aftertaste from that.
- What's this flavor again?
- Smokey potato butter.
I can taste the smokiness of it.
- I can taste the butter as well.
- Oh Jesus, that's awful.
Another one from Natural Lawson,
so there are two types of Lawsons.
- I'm getting very full, gentlemen.
(laughing)
We're nearly done, we're nearly done.
There is the Natural Lawson's,
which tends to have more
healthy options, healthy snacks,
healthy meals.
It's actually pretty good.
It's a pretty cool marketing strategy.
And so they have their own brand of stuff
and this is their cranberry
cookies with GABA.
- Cranberry cookies?
- GABA?
- GABA it says.
- Isn't GABA like the stuff
they put in energy drinks?
- Oh yeah it is isn't it?
- Kuranberi kuki.
Is what it says in Japanese.
- Very good Japanese.
Nihongo Jouzu!
- I was looking for GABA.
And I was like, where's GABA?
- It's literally at the top, it says GABA.
- GABA.
- You wanna point it at the camera?
- They literally spell GABA in English.
- They're just like fuck it.
- Just gave up on learning the language.
- [Meilyne] It's enriched chocolate.
- Enriched chocolate?
- That's what GABA is?
- It has aminobutyric acid?
- Aminobutyric acid.
- [Joey] I know exactly what that is.
- This is supposed to be healthy, so,
what is it, like...
- Yeah so the stuff at Natural Lawson
is way more healthy, so
it should be healthier.
- So, one of these is,
is that a one, one bag?
65 calories, is that right?
17.5 grams.
- Oh that's nothing.
- Oh that might be.
I'll just give it a shot anyway.
You can tell me Joey, I'll hand it to you.
- There you go.
- Thank you.
- Okay.
Ooh, this looks like a diet.
This looks like a diet.
- Like a belVita?
- Yeah, this looks like a diet snack.
It looks like a diet bar honestly.
- How many calories, is it
bag, or like, what is it?
- So it's per meal.
- Meal?
- Meal.
- Which is 17 and a half grams.
Oh, this is 35 grams, so, okay, so, two.
- So this is 100.
- So half a bag is 65 calories.
- That's not bad.
- For what looks to be
like a very heavy snack.
- Yeah.
Let's have a taste.
- That's literally like a belVita.
- It is a belVita.
- What's a belVita?
- It's like the diet like, cookies,
or diet biscuits with like,
they have them in every country.
- This tastes something like
my grandma would've had.
It's like grandma, can I have some snacks?
And she's like here you go.
- That's not actually, I quite like that.
- I like that.
- That's nice.
- Actually, if I had a
Natural Lawson's closer to me,
I'd probably get that.
- Yeah.
- That's actually, fuck.
- Cranberry flavored stuff
is actually really good.
- Yeah I'm taking that home with me.
(laughing)
Put it in a little Ziploc bag.
Fantastic.
- Should we talk about
some of the stuff at the front here?
- Okay, yeah, I wanna talk about this.
I already like these.
These are the ramune flavored...
- Candy?
- Candy.
- I have an ancient video on my channel
from like six years
ago where I bought like
a box of those candy.
And I said to myself,
would I be able to change
ramune candy back to ramune?
(laughing)
This ancient video on my channel,
it's still up there.
- What is this,
a Vsauce video?
- So what I did was I
emptied out like 30 of these
- [Connor] No don't put it on the table,
you'll get grease on there.
- into a ball.
- No, no, no, oh god.
- I emptied like 30 of these into a ball,
and I crushed them into a powder,
and then I mixed it with carbonated water,
to see if it would go back into a ramune.
Spoilers!
It doesn't go back into a ramune.
- I only ever had the drink a few times.
It's quite nice.
- Ramune is basically what,
how would you describe ramune?
It's basically like Japanese lemonade?
Right?
- Yeah, Japanese lemonade.
I love these.
This.
- You love this?
- Dude I grew up with this shit.
- This is like eating a kid's cereal.
- I eat this, and I'm like,
I taste a childhood I never had.
- No wonder you don't like tengone,
because you're fucking eating
kid's shit all the time!
What, were you drinking like
breast milk still all the time?
What's going on?
- It's a secret.
- I would eat this.
What Connor has right there, Choco-babies.
- I love these.
- These are great.
- These are like,
these are terrible though, 'cause like,
you think you're not
eating a lot of chocolate.
But it's so fucking dense.
- I look at this and I thought
it was gonna be a Tic-Tac.
- [Joey] Right, right, right.
- The first time I tried
it I thought it was,
it looks like a Tic-Tac.
And then you bite into it and it's just.
It's just like--
- It's pure chocolate.
- Pure chocolate is rare though.
- It's the most inoffensive
chocolate that it's like,
it's the good chocolate
you would eat as a kid.
- Gimme gimme.
You're opening it.
There's a tag at the bottom.
- There was a tag, it
doesn't matter, I did it.
- You did it.
- Yeah, literally just,
Tic Tac chocolate version.
- Pretty much.
- It makes chocolate way too easy to eat.
Because you just.
- The supermarkets have the big versions.
And if I get them, it's almost impossible
not to eat it in one day.
- 'Cause it's like,
it's like eating sprinklings.
- Oh that's my childhood
right there, lads.
- Like this big as well.
- Tiny.
- That's my childhood right there.
- That's really nice milk chocolate.
Mmm.
That's good shit.
- The other thing though
that is my childhood,
is these things, Umaibo.
- Oh I hate these.
(laughing)
These suck.
- Have you tried these?
- No.
- Oh yeah, you can try it.
- So these.
They're literally called Umaibo,
which means tasty stick.
That's literally what it's called.
- [Garnt] Okay.
- And it's basically, oh god,
how do you even explain it?
- So basically there's like,
these have been around
since like the fucking 20's.
These are ancient.
And they're 10 yen each.
Alright?
Fucking nothing.
But feel how light that is.
- These are the Space Raiders.
These are the Space
Raiders of Japan I think.
- This is packaged air.
- If you throw this high
enough into the air,
it'll just go off to the stratosphere.
- This has no weight at all.
- What's the actual weight
written on the package?
- Oh.
Six grams.
- Six grams.
- [Joey] Six grams, but I guarantee--
- I'm pretty sure most of the grams
is the packaging.
- Is the packaging.
- Is the fucking packaging,
I'm literally holding air here.
- So I have the corn potage flavored.
Which is like corn.
- Dude this just looks like,
these just look like Monster's crisps.
- Oh mine's, I got the cheese one.
- You should try it.
- What is this flavor?
- This is the mentaiko
flavor, the cod roe flavor.
- This is just Monster's crisps, isn't it?
- No it's like Monster's crisps
if they were made by Space Raiders.
(laughing)
- Did you have Space Raiders in Australia?
- I've heard of those, yeah.
- Oh.
- Alright, let's try it.
(crunching)
- It's a big Wotsit.
- It takes away all the
moisture in your mouth though.
- Yeah, It's a Monster's crisp.
- It's just a Wotsit.
It's a big Wotsit.
This isn't cheese, it's just a Wotsit.
- Honestly, I mean,
I can understand why
that was your childhood.
- Americans, this is a Cheeto.
That's what this is.
- I honestly, dude, imagine,
you're like a five year old, right?
You're given like 100 yen
of like, just, you know,
pocket money from your
grandma or something.
- Of course you're buying 10 of these.
- I'm buying 10 of these.
Like these motherfuckers are
gonna fill me up until dinner.
- Honestly.
I mean, who doesn't love fucking Wotsits
or Monster's crisps or whatever?
(laughs)
- Just cheese sticks.
- Oh chikama, yeah.
- I can guarantee though,
that these are probably not
the best tasting cheese.
- Look, I also grew up with these,
but after about age eight,
I stopped eating them,
because I had proper cheese in Australia.
- When you have real
cheese, you can't eat this.
- But if you're American,
and not from Wisconsin.
- But this is not just cheese,
this is cheese with
kamaboko, which is fish cake.
(sighs)
- You shouldn't have said that,
you should've let him try it.
- Just give it a go.
- Wanna try it, Garnt?
- Sure.
- You're on the show, you
can't say no any more.
- I can't say no.
I'm actually
really fucking full.
- Look at that.
- What the fuck is this?
- What the fuck?
- What?
- Kamachi, kama.
- How the hell do I describe.
- I've never had one of these.
- How do you eat these, Joey?
- I'm gonna be honest.
This is probably the least
appetizing looking thing
that we've had on today.
- Ugh.
- You kinda just rip it open like that.
- We've had some pretty gross shit,
but this looks vile.
This actually looks disgusting.
- This looks like on the same level as
squirty cheese, almost.
- What's the ratio of cheese
to like, fish?
- You don't wanna smell them.
(laughs)
- How do I open this?
- This immediately, just
like, grab the top and just,
down like a banana.
(laughing)
These boys are strong.
Here, I'll open them up
for you, there you go.
- Let me get this one.
- There you go, just get a knife.
- Fucking hell.
- Oh okay.
- Fort Knox should be...
- This actually tastes,
this actually smells
close to vomit, I think.
As close to vomit
as you can--
- It's like cheesy vomit,
isn't it?
- Yeah, that's it.
- Alright, I'm gonna have one.
'Cause I haven't had these.
- Smell it, smell it.
- Oh.
- I haven't had one of these
since I was about eight.
- Okay, is this gonna
be cheese flavored vomit
like I imagine it to be?
- Yeah.
It tastes exactly how I remember it.
- Oh.
- Boomer tries Japanese
snack for first time.
- Honestly it doesn't taste
as bad as I thought it would.
- No, no, no.
- It tastes like you're eating plastic.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It tastes like you're eating plastic
and then you get the fish aftertaste.
- Where is the cheese in that?
I don't taste any fucking cheese.
- That was not cheese, that was plastic.
- That's a plastic fish sausage.
- That's fish flavored plastic.
- I have a Melty Kiss, as they're called.
- Meruti Kissu!
- Meruti Kissu, as they
say in all the commercials.
- And I don't particularly like these.
- [Joey] You don't?
- It's just, mochi, right?
Am I eating mochi, kind of?
- It's like mochi with
like chocolate on it.
- Yeah, well.
Let's give it a shot, shall we?
- You're not a fan of mochi?
- Mochi's hit or miss for me.
- Of course, because it's Japan,
they're individually packaged.
- Yeah.
- Love the packaging.
- Say what you will.
It's fucking pretty.
Like the box makes you wanna get it.
- The thing about Melty Kiss
is Melty Kiss is one of
those brands in Japan
that is always seasonal.
They always have a seasonal
flavor of Melty Kiss.
You can tell what time period you are in
when you go to a supermarket or a konbini,
and you see what Melty
Kisses are on for sale.
- And as the name suggests,
they melt pretty fucking fast.
- So I really like it.
It's...
- Mmm.
I like it.
- It is just basically
mochi, with chocolate.
- Mm-mm-mm-mm-mm.
Mm.
- And it's just basically--
- I'd fuck with that.
- Actually you know what?
That's really good.
- Yeah.
- I don't know what Melty Kiss you have.
- I think I had an awful like tasting one.
This is just chocolate,
this is fucking good.
- This is chocolate truffle.
- This is really rich chocolate.
- It's just chocolate truffle, right?
- There's no mochi in this is there?
Is there?
- I think so.
- There might be a mochi variant.
- Oh I thought it was mochi.
So I tasted that, I
didn't taste any mochi.
- It's like a truffle, yeah.
- Yeah that's just chocolate truffle.
- I think that's just truffle butter
with chocolate.
- I'd fuck with that,
and thank god they're
all individually wrapped
so we can enjoy those later.
- Yeah.
- I also have, this is mochi though.
- That's the mochi.
- That's mochi.
- There you go.
- What is this?
Mochi, mochi...
Oh my god, I can't read fucking the font.
- Come on, you're Nihongo Jouzu.
You can do it.
- Shi-yo-ra?
Shiyora?
- Shiora.
- Shiora?
- Shoyura?
- So cute just trying to,
for them trying to figure it out.
- Bro, it's the fancy fonts
fuck me up in Japanese so much.
- It's shokora.
- Oh that's ko!
Oh, okay.
- That looks like a yu doesn't it?
- I thought that was yu as well.
- Yu would be, yu, the
bottom would be more...
- Yeah, yeah, I thought it was.
It's got a little bit there.
- I remember the yu,
it looks like an iron.
- That's fancy.
- Looks like an iron!
- That's how I remember the
yu, it looks like an iron!
- That's cute.
So it's separated into
cute little packages.
- Oh cute.
- Okay.
- Dude, that's like perfect for dates.
- Yeah.
- Yeah man.
You and your GF, rocking
out with the mochi.
- Okay, how do you feel about mochi?
- Mid tier.
- It depends.
It depends on the type.
Like mochi ice cream
and like regular mochi.
And like sweet mochis is
like completely different
in my opinion.
- And so what is mochi again?
- Mochi is just rice.
It's rice pudding.
- Yeah so, mochi's just rice pudding.
- So basically they grab mochi rice,
which is a specific type of rice.
And they just fucking
mash it with a hammer
until it turns into mochi.
- It's good.
- It's very chewy.
- This is good shit.
That's clean.
- Mm.
- How I always feel about mochi
is that it's just very inoffensive.
I would never not eat mochi.
But I would never go out
my way to get it as well.
- But you know like a
lot of old people die
from choking on mochi.
- I can see why.
- So when you're eating mochi
make sure you like--
- Shit fights back.
- Yeah.
Make sure you like,
properly chew this shit,
otherwise it will get
stuck in your throat.
- I'm sorry I'm just laughing 'cause I saw
one of Garnt's item, I keep
forgetting it's called this.
It's called the chocolate pound cake.
For some reason that feels so,
that has such a sexual energy to it.
- That is like, I never
thought about that,
I was like, yeah, poundo cake, of course.
But when you say it in
English, it's really weird.
- That's the chocolate pound cake.
- Chocolate pound cake.
- Yo girl, you wanna get
some chocolate pound cake?
- Yeah see?
That has like, I've never had a food item
that has raw sexual energy.
But that has it.
- Ay yo shawty!
(laughing)
Y'all want a chocolate pound cake?
- What that pound cake do?
(laughing)
- Honestly?
I mean it's just cake.
- That's just a fat block of chocolate.
Yeah I'll fuck with that, gimme that.
- I know what this tastes like.
- Yeah I know what this tastes like.
- Garnt.
When Garnt has run out of energy.
He'll run into the 7-11
or like, Family Mart,
and just buy one of
these and just devour it.
- Yeah, I don't know how
you do that to be honest.
- Sometimes I just need a sugar rush.
I don't know.
- It's just a brownie.
- Yeah.
That literally just tastes
like a brownie, yeah.
- It's good though.
- I mean, it's just a brownie.
I don't need to describe that taste.
- But it's way more sexually
sounding than a brownie.
The pound cake.
- Pound cake does sound
better than brownie.
- Hold up the camera.
That's nice, right?
- Yeah.
- That's not bad.
- That's sexy.
- Hmm.
- Alright, I think we are
almost done, right?
- Joey, what'd you have?
- I've got these like,
chocolate pies.
- Pain de chocolat?
- Choco pie.
- Oh god no.
- Yeah.
- That looks fucking awful.
- That just looks like
a pain de chocolat.
- Yeah, but like not as good.
- France is crying right now.
- I don't really fuck
with these to be honest.
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna be honest.
I don't need to try that.
- I don't need to try that.
- Let's not open that.
- Let's open the stuff
that is like, only...
- What is that, Garnt?
What the fuck is that Kit-Kat?
- This is a melon Kit-Kat.
- You're kidding me.
Why?
- Melon Kit-Kat?
- They have, yeah.
- That's a Hokkaido melon Kit-Kat, too,
that's the good melons.
- See the thing about Hokkaido melons
is that it is expensive as fuck here.
'Cause apparently it
tastes fucking super amazing.
- Open that bitch up.
- Hokkaido melons, for reference is like,
one of like, maybe about that big.
But a regular thing will
cost you like two, $300.
It's like the top class of melon.
Oh.
Oh this is the ball variety
that we tried before.
- Is this just gonna
taste like Kit-Kat again?
- Whoa.
- I'd fuck with that.
I love melon flavored shit.
- Holy shit that's good.
- That's really good.
- Oh my god.
- That might be one of
the best ones I've tried.
Hey, gimme some of that.
- That's probably the best Kit-Kat
I've ever had in my life.
What the fuck.
- That has such a clean flavor to it.
Like--
- That straight up tastes
like you're eating a melon.
- Yeah.
- Wow.
That's crazy.
- It's like, the crunchiness
of a biscuit and a Kit-Kat,
but with the clean taste of a fruit.
- Wow.
- I can't...
- That's really good.
- Wow.
- You know how you bite
into a melon, and it just--
- Fuck, Kit-Kat, goddamn.
- You know how you bite into
a melon and it just like,
it feels like clean,
because it feels like you're eating
like a really watery fruit.
For some reason that was
a completely dry snack
that we just had,
but it felt watery.
- But it felt watery, right?
Yeah, yeah.
- What the fuck is this
Sugar Butter Sand Tree?
- We don't need to try that.
- It's called Sugar Butter Sand Tree.
- What the fuck is that?
- It just looks like a custard cream.
- Oh it's a 7-11 brand too.
- Oh fuck that.
I have...
(chuckles)
Wasabi sticks, it looks like.
Is that cheese and wasabi?
- Oh that's Jagariko,
which is like a brand
of like, savory sticks.
And I guess this is wasabi shoyu flavored.
- Do you like wasabi snacks?
- No.
- I do not get them.
- I like the wasabi like, beans.
The wasabi seed, like flavored things.
I forgot what they were called, but like.
- I know what you're talking about.
- It's like the peanut
and the like, wasabi food.
- There's like beans that
are covered in wasabi.
- Yeah, I fuck with those.
- Let me smell this bad boy.
- I don't know.
For me, wasabi just doesn't feel
like something that should be snacked on.
(crunching)
That's basic as fuck.
- Did you taste anything?
- I don't taste anything.
I taste the wasabi, yeah.
- I barely, oh a little bit, tiny bit.
- Oh yeah, there it is.
- Because when we eat
something wasabi flavored,
we're used to the whole
like, kickback, right?
But this is just like, literally,
just a hint of wasabi flavor.
- Honestly?
- It's not too overpowering, I like that.
Fuck yes.
I literally was just
shitting on wasabi snacks
literally five minutes ago
and that's because the wasabi,
normally what happens
with wasabi snacks is that
it overpowers whatever you're eating.
- Like I can probably taste the soy sauce
in that as well.
- I ate that.
And I was like, I can't
even taste the wasabi,
but then, you get that aftertaste.
- You literally just did
like the kombucha girl like,
mm-hmm?
(laughing)
You're like, ew, wasabi, actually,
these are pretty good.
- Yeah because, you know
when you have bad sushi,
and then you kind of like try
to overpower it with wasabi
just to get rid of the taste
of the bad sushi.
- No, I don't do that.
What?
Who does that?
Do you do that?
- Sometimes.
- What?
- But like, I don't find myself
in a bad sushi restaurant.
I know a good one.
- No, no, no.
- Joey was Louie.
He didn't go into a bad sushi.
- I don't go to that
100 yen bullshit sushi.
- You go to some sushi restaurants,
especially with friends from abroad,
and you see them like, put
a little bit of soy sauce,
and then fucking wasabi.
And then it's like 90%
wasabi, 10% soy sauce,
and they just basically
just dip the entire
sushi in the wasabi.
- [Joey] And they drown it
in that shit.
- They fucking drown it in.
And I don't know how
they can taste the fish.
- That's the incorrect way to eat sushi.
- Finally, oh go ahead.
- And I feel like this is
the perfect kind of balance
of like, how a good
sushi should taste like.
- I really like those actually.
- Damn, when's the Gigguk
video coming out about these?
You went on a fucking rant there
about how beautiful they were.
- But, final thing we have
is the classic.
- Matcha.
- [Joey] Matcha.
- We could've had about
a bazillion matcha items
we wanted to I think.
- Honestly, I think matcha
is my favorite kind of snack.
- Weren't you the guy
like seven months ago
who thought matcha was overrated?
- I don't think so.
- No, I don't think that was Garnt.
- That wasn't Garnt?
I thought it was Garnt.
- It was someone else.
That's the thing.
- I think matcha's overhyped.
I'm just saying.
- I feel that's like the--
- Okay, so you're the guy who
thinks matcha's overhyped.
- I think matcha's
also overhyped.
- I feel there's
the two dichotomies with matcha though.
It's either you think it's
fucking amazing with everything,
or you think it's overrated as fuck.
- There's too much matcha stuff.
- I mean in the last podcast we recorded,
I had a matcha latte.
- Take a stick there.
- To me matcha is kind of like,
sometimes I'll eat one, sometimes,
it's like handing a
cigarette over isn't it?
(laughing)
- Alright, let's fucking try it.
- Gentlemen.
- I've had these before, these are great.
- Yeah, these are great.
- I mean.
It's fine.
- Matcha snacks are great.
- I'd rather a chocolate based thing.
- Honestly have you, okay.
One question.
Have you ever had matcha soft serve?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause matcha soft serve
- I quite like that,
to be fair.
- is literally the,
single handedly changed
my opinion of matcha.
'Cause after I had matcha soft serve,
I'm like, matcha tastes fucking great.
- Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Oh we have more, sorry, I forgot.
We have this thing which
is, go-ha-na desu yo?
- Nihongo Jouzu.
- Gohandesuyo.
- Gohandesuyo which is
basically this like,
I don't even know what
the flavor of it is.
It's just Gohandesuyo flavored.
But basically you--
- Can I smell it?
- You put it on a bed of rice,
and it basically, it's good on rice,
that's all it is.
- Bruh, you're kidding me.
- Can I smell that?
- That smells like seaweed.
- [Meilyne] It's seaweed paste.
- It's a seaweed paste.
- You would give this to like, kids.
- I think I inhaled an X amount of salt
just from being near that.
- Well that's the thing.
Because it's so salty,
you put that on a bed of rice,
and it mellows it out perfectly.
- This is, I'm not gonna eat that.
- I'm not eating that.
- This is Jaga Choco.
And it's just potato chips, it looks like.
- With chocolate.
- Just chocolate.
- Chocolate potato chips.
- Looks like it hasn't been,
you know what, fuck it,
I can make assumptions all day.
As the great lord says,
let's just jump right into it.
Oh.
- Oh, okay.
- Okay.
- Okay, that's...
- A little...
- Oh yeah, I think I've
tried these before.
- Looking a little anemic, dare I say.
- I mean it's literally just
a chocolate potato chip.
- Will it be salty though?
That's what I'm curious about.
- Yes.
- They are weirdly salty.
- You can't taste the chocolate,
there's too much salt.
- I'm having a kombucha
tea moment right now.
(snickering)
- It's like, mm, mm?
Not gonna lie.
It's a little too much salt for me.
- A little too much.
- You know what that tastes like?
It tastes like you ate a bag of crisps,
and then you instantly downed
it with like a hot chocolate.
- If I'm gonna
- That's what that tastes like.
- get double calories of
eating crisps and chocolate,
I wanna enjoy both, right?
I don't wanna like, have one,
and then just eat calories
for no fucking reason.
- I gotta cleanse my palate with this.
- What is that one thing
you have over there, Joey?
- I'm having like
an existential moment.
- What's that polar bear thing you have?
- It's basically,
what the fuck this this?
Konayuki Shokora.
It's basically Melty Kiss I think.
- Is it really?
- It's kind of the same thing.
- Crack it open, let's try it out.
- It's like a brownie I
guess, let's try it out.
- This is giving me an
existential crisis right now.
- Garnt, just keep eating it.
- Oh, they're big.
- [Connor] Whoa.
- Look at the packaging it comes in dude,
that's fancy as fuck,
- Whoa.
What is that?
- [Joey] I don't know.
Let's crack it open though.
- Garnt, are you okay?
- No, I'm not okay.
- It's not good Garnt.
Why are we deciding if it's good or not?
- Because it tastes good,
and then it doesn't,
and then it does, and then it doesn't,
and then it, ugh.
I'm so fucking confused.
- It's like, yeah, again,
it's like a Melty Kiss,
but kind of more fancy looking.
- Just wanna grab one.
- Just grab one.
Just pop it out.
There we are.
It's like a mini brownie.
- Whoa.
Oh it's not like a mini brownie.
- Oh it's like if snow was chocolate.
- Oh actually it says
powder snow chocolate.
There you go.
The branding on point.
- Man that's so rich.
- That instantly melts away.
- Holy fuck.
- [Joey] You wanna try that?
- Hold on.
- You still having an
existential crisis with that one?
- I think I like this.
- [Joey] Really?
- It took me three bites.
- After much deliberation, lads.
- I didn't hear whatever
you guys were talking about.
'cause I was--
- Guys, he likes it.
- I was just trying to figure out
if this was a taste that I like, and,
this tastes pretty good.
- He was like having like
an ancient Greek like
philosophy like Aristotle
moment in his head
while we were eating this.
- So what is it that you're talking about?
What is this?
- This is powder snow chocolate.
It literally just melts away.
That is (mumbling).
- This man can't make
up his mind on anything!
- This honestly has fucked me up,
'cause I'm just like,
do I like things now?
What do I like any more?
What is life?
- (burps) Oh god, I feel sick.
- I don't eat chocolate, but this is
more chocolate than I've had in so long.
- This is,
remember how we were debating
if we were gonna have dinner
after filming this episode?
- That ain't happening.
- We are not having
dinner after this episode.
- I just enjoy the atmosphere
of having a dinner together.
I didn't get that atmosphere.
- This is not a dinner with the boys.
You literally just witnessed three people
have dinner together.
- Over two hours.
- Yeah for two hours.
- A literal konbini dinner.
- So lads, like, what would
you say is your favorite
I guess, item from each genre of food?
- So are we starting
with the hot foods first?
- Yeah, so hot foods, which one,
which one reigns supreme in the hot foods?
- Okay, hot food, I'm
still stanning Seven.
Seven, if you want a meal.
- Lawson fried chicken.
Lawson fried chicken man.
- Seven fried chicken.
Seven beef bowl.
Seven any hot food tastes great.
- Honestly, I think Lawson have been doing
the hot food better, man.
Gotta be real with you man.
- If I'm gonna be the mediator,
I would have to just give it to Seven.
- Yes!
- You fucking,
are you for real?
- Yes!
- I'd have to just give it to Seven
for the hot food.
- You're not a clown, Joey,
you're the whole circus.
- Again, I don't eat the fried food,
so I don't fucking care.
All we know is that Family
Mart fried food sucks arse.
- I never get the fried
food from the konbini
'cause I'm just like, if I'm gonna...
- If I'm gonna have fried food,
I'm gonna go to a fucking restaurant.
- Yeah, if I'm gonna fuck up my body,
I'ma do it in a good place.
you know what I mean?
- Pay good money to fuck up your body.
- I want the best shit if this
is like my cheat day, right?
What are the best like, sandwiches, then?
- Oh, sandwich.
- Probably Lawson's.
- Have I converted you into seeing the way
of the tuna sandwich from Lawson's?
- Look, the tuna sandwich,
Lawson is definitely better.
But the egg sandwich,
Family Mart's better.
- If only they could join forces.
- Yeah, I would agree with that.
- Like runny egg sandwiches
should never be a thing.
- It's not runny.
- Ooh, I don't know about that.
- It's a paste.
It's mashed up.
- It's the collab we want to happen.
- Japan, we're waiting.
- Like egg paste shouldn't be a thing.
- It's not paste, it's just mashed down.
- I wanna taste the egg slices.
- I want the texture of the egg.
- I don't need it.
- I need it.
- I would prefer it, but.
- Even scrambled egg has a texture.
This was like, scrambled egg
that was put into a paste.
It is...
- I like it.
- It's like egg flavored glue.
That's what it tastes like.
- To me, the egg is like,
they're both very strong.
But to me the tuna is just so much better.
- The tuna is hands down better.
- It's like, why would I want it?
And also, like, there's
supermarkets that like,
aren't any of those that get like,
the sandwiches as well,
and the tuna always tastes
like the Family Mart one for some reason.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- For some reason just
Lawson's tuna.
- I feel the Lawson one
they actually took like the canned tuna
and just put it in.
- Yeah, it's good shit.
It's good fucking shit.
- I feel like the Lawson's one,
the tuna sandwich is
better, definitely better.
The egg sandwiches from Family
Mart were definitely better.
- I don't eat that many
sandwiches from the konbinis,
so I don't really have too
much of a strong opinion.
- I'm so full.
- What about the onigiri, the rice balls?
- Lawson's.
- Yeah, Lawson's hands down.
- Lawson's hands down.
- Of a sample size of one type.
- I did not realize though,
that because we saw two Seven onigiris,
I don't know if one will
make it to the final cut,
but we opened up two.
They both looked as
depressing as each other.
My god.
- They're pretty sad.
- The Lawson one was clean.
It was nicely wrapped around.
- That was an art piece
right there.
- And the fillings were
in every single bite.
No matter where I bite,
I need to get a bit of filling.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Lawson's hit it on the mark.
- Lawson's definitely
by far the best onigiri.
- Thank you guys, thank you.
Appreciate the love.
- What about the,
what else did we cover?
I guess snacks?
- We had like the like,
fish snacks, meat snacks.
- I mean the fish snacks and meat snacks
I think we can all agree
are all pretty mid.
- They're all like the same level.
- I don't know I liked the fish crisps.
- Oh the Lawson fish crisps.
- Yeah yeah.
- Yeah yeah yeah yeah.
- I think the way that
Lawson's do the squid as well
is really fucking good.
- We unfortunately didn't
get to try any like,
dried squid or dried
fish or something, but,
like it's something that
a lot of people from, you
know, America and England
that I've met have,
'cause I bring this shit
from Thailand to England,
and people are like, why
are you eating fish food?
(laughs)
'Cause it kinda does smell
a bit like fish food.
- A little bit, yeah.
- It does, but it tastes fucking awesome.
It's the perfect amount of salty,
it's perfect to go with your beer.
Fish snacks just, you can't like,
you don't know the full
enjoyment of fish snacks
until you've had a cold
beer with them I feel.
- Yeah, you gotta have a beer with them.
- And I must say,
I'm thoroughly impressed
with the One Cup, personally.
I thought I was gonna fucking hate this.
I finished it.
- I'm impressed.
- I'm impressed, I thought
it was gonna taste like shit,
and it tasted, not great, but drinkable.
Way better than Chris's.
(laughing)
- I would buy another one of this.
- What the fuck, did
Chris just bring us like,
just like the budget, yeah.
- Expired sake.
- The worst one he could find?
- He just like pissed in a bottle,
was like, yeah, it's sake, trust me.
- So potent that it had alcohol in it.
- Okay.
- My favorite snack I think has gotta be
the Kit-Kat, watermelon.
- Yeah the Kit-Kat watermelon.
- The melon Kit-Kat.
You mean the melon?
Just the rock melon, right?
- The Kit-Kat melon, yeah.
- The melon Kit-Kat.
Yeah.
- That was fucking amazing.
- I also really like these though.
- I liked them, but I
think the Kit-Kat melon
was just above the rest.
- And then obviously
there's like--
- All the breads
disappointed me.
- Yeah, the breads were kinda mid.
- This though.
- No, no, no, no.
- No it's not.
- Lemme just--
- Choco babies, Garnt,
get the fuck out of here!
- Yeah, and again, like,
you know, like the ramune
and stuff like that, the choco baby,
the stuff that I grew up with.
That shit's great.
- Oh, I'm so full.
- What, you having another
existential crisis right now?
- Fuck, I took a bite,
and I was just like,
this tastes awful, and then I'm just like,
no this tastes good.
You gotta fucking try
this, please try this.
(laughing)
- You don't have to.
- I've got it.
The initial taste tastes fucking awful.
- [Joey] Right.
- And then the aftertaste
kicks in and I'm like,
this tastes like,
the aftertaste gives me
the same kind of taste.
When you're cooking like
a brownie or something
and you have like cooking chocolate.
And you're cooking like
a chocolate pudding.
And then as a kid you kinda just like,
have a bit of the chocolate.
You know.
- It doesn't taste like that.
- You scoop a bit
into your mouth.
- Not gonna like, I wasn't listening,
I was just enjoying Connor
looking dead over there.
(laughing)
- It doesn't taste like
that, you're chatting shit.
- But all in all, I'd
have to say, you can get.
Like this is not even.
- You're a winner
if you're in Japan,
'cause you get to have all of this.
- This is not even a corner
of what you can get at a konbini.
- Fuck the best tasting thing.
What was the worst tasting thing?
- [Joey] Oh god.
- Okay.
'Cause I'm having a hard
time deciding between this.
And this.
- No, honestly?
The crab cake.
The crab cake was the worst.
- Oh, the crab cake was pretty bad.
- Crab cake was the worst.
- No, actually.
It's this for me.
This has a worse
aftertaste than crab cake.
I still have the aftertaste of this
in my mouth right now
after eating all that.
- Shit was gross.
- Yeah, I mean, again.
- Oh god.
- I grew up with chikama
and there's a reason
why I stopped eating it.
Cause it's gross.
- That ain't right.
- [Joey] It ain't right.
- It literally smells like vomit.
- Yeah, it ain't right.
- That was probably
the worst flavored one.
- That was the worst thing.
- But yeah, again, this is nowhere near
the variety that you can get
at a convenience store, right?
Like, there's so many more
snacks, I mean, you know.
Haven't even talked about
the fact that you know,
you can buy basically fucking anything
at a convenience store, right?
- You can pay your utility bills.
You can send packages.
- You can pay your rent
at a konbini.
- Yeah you can send packages.
- You can send packages.
You can get toiletries.
- What can't you do?
- You can get, you know, like--
- Lawson's next to me has now basically
just has a whole section
for like household items.
So like you can buy like bedsheets.
And like soap containers.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And like, weird shit that you're like,
why do I need this here?
It's like a mini Ikea in Lawson's.
It's so strange.
But really cool.
- You can buy stuff like,
you can buy technical stuff like SD cards
and USB sticks as well.
- Like chargers and stuff like that.
- Deodorant.
- I've bought underwear
from Family Mart before.
- I have a pair of,
honestly the best pair of
socks I've bought in Japan
are from Lawson's.
- From Lawson's!
- They're really fucking...
- I have gloves.
Like hand gloves that I
bought from Family Mart
and I still wear them to this day.
- Yeah, right?
So super super convenient.
So like, definitely
when you come to Japan,
whenever the world opens up.
Yeah.
- Let us know what your favorite is.
- Yeah, let us know what your favorite is!
Yeah.
It might be neither of
our favorite, right?
It could be Ministop, it
could be Yamazaki, who knows?
- And let Chris Broad
know that his shit taste
thinking that Family
Mart chicken is the best.
- Family Mart chicken is not the best.
- That's the real loser here.
Family Mart chicken sucks.
- The real loser is the fact
that Chris thinks that Family
Mart chicken tastes good.
- Please, if you come to Japan.
Please go to Family Mart Chicken.
Family Mart, get the
chicken, and just, you know,
validate our opinion.
Because it's fucking awful.
- Please be disappointed.
- Also let us know if
you enjoyed this episode,
which is a very different
format to our usual.
- Yeah, we just kind of
wanted to try this out,
to kind of, you know,
give you guys something
a little bit different than just us
chatting shit for two hours.
- Hey we're just experimenting this time.
- Which we will get back to very shortly.
- Yeah, absolutely.
But in the meantime, look
at all these Patrons!
- Wow, look at this guy here.
- Look at that guy and that guy
and that guy.
- He hates
Family Mart chicken.
- This guy doesn't eat
crab cakes with cheese.
- But yeah, if you guys
would like to support us,
make sure to go to patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also, send us your memes
on Twitter, the Subreddit,
and listen to us on Spotify.
Maybe not this episode.
Don't listen to this episode on Spotify.
- It's a bit late if you
got this far in the audio.
- Yeah yeah.
- Yeah yeah yeah.
- We warned you right at the beginning.
But every other episode you can probably
listen to on Spotify.
- Apologies to any audio only listeners
who have attempted to
get through this episode.
- They're just like, imagining
what everything looks like.
Just like (grunting).
- They probably had a nice like,
two hour eating ASMR.
- Yeah, just a lot of chewing noises.
- World's slowest mukbang.
(laughing)
- But yeah guys.
- I'm exhausted from eating so much.
- Garnt, stop!
- I want like a proper meal,
so let's just go do that.
Alright guys, thanks for
enjoying this strange episode.
We'll get back to your regular
scheduled program soon,
but in the meantime, have a good one!
Bye!
Stop eating them!
- No, I don't like it, I don't like it.
(groovy music)